bien mesdames messieurs
nous retrouvons donc aujourd'hui les
travaux de notre commission d'enquête
chargé d'établir les raisons de la perte
de souveraineté d'indépendance la France
pour deux auditions aujourd'hui et nous
commençons par celles de Monsieur
Eric Besson monsieur le ministre nous
vous remercions d'avoir accepté de venir
devant notre commission
parmi les diverses fonctions
ministérielles que vous avez exercées
celle que vous avez assumée de 2010 à
2012 lorsque vous étiez chargé de
l'énergie et rattachée au ministère de
l'économie des finances et de
l'industrie retient tout
particulièrement notre attention
vos responsabilités étaient étendues le
décret relatif à vos attributions vous
confie le soin d'élaboré et de mettre en
oeuvre la politique de l'énergie et des
matières premières notamment pour je
cite assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et la compétitivité
de l'économie
deux événements importants se sont
produits au cours de l'exercice de vos
fonctions qui ont infléchi les
politiques énergétiques de plusieurs
pays le sommet de Copenhague d'abord sur
le climat organisé en 2009 puis
l'accident de Fukushima survenu en 2011
en Europe l'ouverture des marchés
d'électricité et du gaz devenaient
progressivement une réalité
la loi de 2010 portant nouvelle
organisation du marché d'électricité la
loi dites nomme plusieurs fois évoqués
lors de nos auditions portent votre
contresens
l'adoption en 2008 sous-présidente
française de l'Union européenne du
paquet énergie climat et le Grenelle de
l'environnement vous ont conduit à
mettre en oeuvre en lien avec Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet qui est en charge de
l'écologie que nous avons déjà
auditionné divers dispositifs visant à
favoriser le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables notamment le lancement
d'un appel d'offres pour un parc éolien
offshore de 3000 mégawatts à
Saint-Nazaire récemment inauguré
appel d'offres dont Nathalie koscius
comoreset nous y dit que c'était un
c'était proche de la poésie
pour reprendre ses mots
enfin je crois
utile de rappeler que vous avez été à
l'initiative d'un rapport intitulé
énergie 2050 confie à Monsieur Claude
Mandil ancien directeur exécutif de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie et
à chaque Perse bois qui était auditionné
par notre commission dès le début de ses
travaux
à la suite de la remise de ce rapport
vous avez défini certaines priorités
parmi lesquelles la réduction de notre
dépendance aux hydrocarbures la maîtrise
de notre consommation le développement
des énergies décarbonées renouvelables
comme nucléaire conduisant à préparer la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
centrales et à poursuivre le programme
de construction de pair avec un deuxième
réacteur à porni
ce ministre je vais vous demander
désormais vous laisser la parole mais
avant cela vous connaissez les règles
applicables aux commissions d'enquête
parlementaire puisque vous avez déjà été
auditionné en 2012 par la commission
d'enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité et donner à cette occasion
de nombreuses informations sur les
composantes et les facteurs d'évolution
de ce coût je vais donc vous demander de
bien vouloir prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité et rien que la
vérité en application des règles qui
s'appliquent au Parlement et en levant
la main droite
en indiquant tout le juré monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie je vous laisse
la parole
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés parce
qu'il contient deux notions clés
l'indépendance et la souveraineté
appliquée qui plus est un secteur
essentiel celui de l'énergie l'intitulé
de votre commission d'enquête pourrait
faire l'objet de belles dissertations
pour des étudiants en sciences
politiques en économie ou en relation
internationales je ne m'y risquerais pas
ce matin et je me contenterai de
suggérer devant vous que l'indépendance
nous est en matière énergétique pour
leur inaccessible du fait de la part des
hydrocarbures importés
nous devons donc rechercher une moindre
dépendance une indépendance relative ne
serait-ce que par la diversification et
la sécurisation des sources
d'approvisionnement par exemple du
pétrole du gaz ou de l'uranium la
souveraineté est un concept un peu
différent donc nous n'avons pas tous la
même définition
si on veut bien considérer que la
souveraineté pour une nation la maîtrise
la plus grande possible de son destin la
souveraineté énergétique passe d'abord
pour la France par la maîtrise de ses
sources de production d'électricité ce
qui signifie concrètement tout faire
pour que les technologies essentielles
que nous utilisons pour en produire nous
appartiennent et que l'essentiel de la
production électrique se fasse sur notre
sol et sous notre maîtrise
dans un domaine crucial
un autre domaine crucial celui de
l'alimentation le pneu du considère que
la souveraineté alimentaire est atteinte
lorsque les États sont en mesure de
garantir que toute personne puisse avoir
accès à une alimentation de qualité en
tout lieu et à toute heure à un prix
acceptable
nous pourrions transposer aisément la
formule et l'appliquer à l'électricité
tous nos concitoyens toutes nos
entreprises doivent pouvoir avoir accès
à toute heure et en tout point du
territoire à une électricité garantie à
un prix abordable évidemment cette
obligation de service continue solide et
compétitif n'est pas incompatible avec
des dispositifs visant à lisser la
demande ou à économiser l'énergie je
pense à l'effacement ou à ecowatts par
exemple
l'énergie le pilotage de la politique
énergétique sont de la responsabilité
première de l'État appartiennent à ce
qu'on appelle le domaine régalien
depuis l'aube des temps l'homme s'est
battu pour maîtriser le feu la chaleur
l'énergie
l'énergie et l'électricité sont à la
base de nos modes de vie de nos
déplacements de nos activités
économiques de nos échanges numériques
de notre industrie
la France a bénéficié pendant plus de 30
ans d'une moindre dépendance d'une
souveraineté relative et l'en bénéficie
encore pour partie
cette souveraineté relative est liée à
une œuvre une action une construction
qui porte un nom le programme
électronucléaire français
ce programme le fameux plan Messmer né
de la volonté du général de Gaulle
annoncé en 1974 sous la présidence
Pompidou mise en œuvre sous les
présidents Giscard d'Estaing et
Mitterrand achevé sous la présidence
Chirac aura été un formidable succès
plus de 50 réacteurs construits en une
vingtaine d'années pour arriver à un
total de 58 une électricité stable
accessible à un prix très compétitif aux
industriels et aux particuliers nous
d'autan de capacités exportatrices
significative tout cela en maintenant un
niveau de sécurité élevé sous le
contrôle d'une autorité de sécurité
nucléaire autorité indépendante reconnue
et exigeante
ainsi si le risque zéro n'existe pas en
matière industrielle et à fortiori pas
dans le monde nucléaire forcer de
constater que tous les gouvernements
l'ASN et l'opérateur EDF n'ont jamais
transigé avec la sûreté et qu'à ce jour
la France n'aura connue qu'un accident
niveau 4 sur une échelle qui est encore
porte 7 l'échelle dite Inès un accident
de niveau 4 je rappelle des finitions
internationales n'entraînant pas de
risques importants à l'extérieur du site
sinon nous n'aurons connu que des
anomalies je cite ou des incidents entre
guillemets pour reprendre la même
classification internationale
il s'agit donc où il s'agissait donc à
quel temps faut-il en parler d'un succès
d'un patrimoine français d'un atout
majeur d'un élément d'attractivité de
compétitivité pour notre pays qui n'en
possède hélas pas autant qu'on le
souhaiterait
si l'on reprend la liste des présidents
que j'ai cités de Gaulle Pompidou
Giscard d'Estaing Mitterrand et Chirac
auquel il convient d'ajouter le
président Sarkozy pour avoir été à
l'origine du lancement du premier repère
celui de Flamanville en tant que
ministre puis du second Pandi en tant
que président finalement arrêté dans les
conditions que vous connaissez on
s'aperçoit que ce succès a été rendu
possible grâce à la grande continuité
d'action grâce aussi à un consensus
politique dépassant les clivages
partisans
dans notre pays hélas ne dispose plus
aujourd'hui j'y reviendrai alors que
d'autres démocraties pourtant très
divisées sur quantité de sujets je pense
aux États-Unis au Royaume-Uni par
exemple continue de bénéficier d'un
consensus politique dans le domaine du
nucléaire civil
en matière de politique énergétique rien
n'est pire que le Stop and Go les
atermoiements les virages à 180 degrés
. en novembre 2010 Jean-Louis Borloo
alors ministre des temps en charge
notamment de l'énergie quitte le
gouvernement le remaniement comporte une
nouvelle architecture gouvernementale le
14 novembre 2010 je suis nommé Ministre
chargé de l'Industrie de l'Énergie et de
l'Économie numérique je suis alors comme
vous l'avez rappelé par délégation du
ministre de l'Économie des Finances en
charge de la politique énergétique de la
production et donc notamment du
nucléaire avec ma collègue Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet nous partageions à la
fois les questions liées à la sûreté
nucléaire et aux énergies renouvelables
point souligner à l'époque l'énergie
retour la Bercy comme disent alors les
commentateurs ce qui au-delà de mon cas
personnel à l'époque m'a toujours paru
cohérent si l'on veut marier politique
énergétique et politique industrielles
ce que je crois absolument indispensable
lorsque j'arrive à Bercy je suis
considéré comme un partisan d'une
nucléaire un défenseur du nucléaire et
c'est vrai j'ai appris à connaître et
apprécié le monde de l'industrie
nucléaire dans la vallée du Rhône en
1995 je suis élu maire d'une commune du
sud de la Drôme Donzère petite commune
de Saint-Denis habitants située à
proximité du site du Tricastin qui fait
partie de la circonscription dont je
serai député de 1997 à 2007 le contact
régulier et passionnant avec les
dirigeants et les salariés de cette
filière me convainquent alors de ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure le
nucléaire civil est un atout et une
force pour notre pays
la France est considérée en 2010-2011
malgré quelques accrocs sur lequel je
reviendrai comme un modèle mondial ou si
vous préférez une formule plus modeste
une référence mondiale dans le domaine
du nucléaire civil 58 réacteurs dont la
disponibilité est forte elle dépasse les
80%. une filière complète qui va de
l'amont du cycle l'approvisionnement
l'uranium et son enrichissement à l'aval
du cycle le retraitement et le stockage
à la Hague le projet lancé de centre
d'enfouissement en couche profonde
par ailleurs notre pays à francisé comme
on dit les licences américaines westingh
qui était à la base de notre programme
nucléaire nous maîtrisons donc la
technologie enfin la France est à leur
en pointe sur de nombreux projets comme
le réacteur de 3e génération le Pr dans
notre pays elle joue un rôle
significatif dans le projet de fusion
thermonucléaire dit ITER dont
l'implantation se fait un Cadarache
le projet Astrid de réacteurs de
quatrième génération et lancer et
bénéficie d'un premier financement de
l'ordre de 600 millions d'euros dans le
cadre de ce que l'on a appelé le grand
emprunt sous la présidence Sarkozy dans
le secteur nucléaire comme dans d'autres
domaines énergétiques le pétrole le gaz
la France dispose alors en 2010-2011
d'entreprises performantes de champion
mondiaux reconnus cela ne signifie pas
qu'il n'y a cette époque aucun nuage
l'un des sujets les plus préoccupants en
2010 et l'absence de coordination de la
filière ou pour parler sans langue de
bois les divergences et mésententes
entre certains acteurs majeurs du
secteur comme le soulignera le rapport
Bruce Lee en juin 2010
d'autant que l'échec français lors de
l'appel d'offre d'Abu Dhabi a résonné
comme une première alerte importante
la feuille de route que me donne alors
le président Sarkozy et le Premier
ministre Fillon est très clair il faut
organiser la filière
je tenterai d'abord de le faire de façon
informelle par la concertation
rapidement après mon arrivée
j'organiserai un déjeuner une après-midi
de travail avec les dirigeants de
l'époque Henri Proglio pour EDF anneau
vergeon pour Areva Gérard mestralet pour
ce qui s'appelait encore GDF Suez
Patrick cron pour Alstom la branche
énergie était alors française ce qu'elle
n'est plus et c'est bien regrettable et
enfin Bernard Bigot pour le CEA
Christophe de Marjorie alors président
de Total n'était pas invité total ayant
renoncé investir dans le secteur
nucléaire après l'échec français aux
Émirats
la deuxième étape fut plus importante et
plus formelle comme l'indique le
compte-rendu du Conseil de politique
nucléaire du 11 février 2011 je reçois
le mandat d'installer un je cite comité
stratégique de l'énergie nucléaire
présidé par le ministre de l'énergie que
j'étais à l'époque et dont le président
d'EDF est à la fois vice-président et
chargée de l'animation du comité de
pilotage
par ailleurs ce même conseil de
politique nucléaire indique je cite
lorsque la France est sollicitée pour
ses compétences d'architectes enseignés
EDF sera le chef de fil de l'industrie
nucléaire française EDF est désormais
chef de fil les nouvelles règles du jeu
sont très claires j'aurais le plaisir
d'installer ce comité stratégique au
Creusot en Bourgogne le 25 juillet 2011
en présence de toutes les parties
prenantes tous les acteurs de la filière
et je crois en tout cas c'est ce qu'ils
ont exprimé à leur grande satisfaction
lors de cette installation trois
premiers thèmes de travail sont
identifiés la compétitivité de la
filière nucléaire les compétences et la
formation et la visibilité du marché à
l'export le même jour en ma présence
sera signé un nouveau partenariat
stratégique technique et commerciales
entre EDF et Areva représentés
respectivement par Henri Proglio pour Ed
et lui Courcelles nous vous président du
directoire
j'aurais l'occasion de réunir une
deuxième fois ce comité stratégique de
cimière le 17 janvier 2012 on y traitera
notamment des conditions d'exercices de
la sous-traitance dans la filière du
d'après ce que l'on m'a rapporté ce
comité a ensuite permis la création du
gifen
groupement des industriels français de
l'énergie nucléaire et a été à l'origine
du salon dit WNE World nucléaire
exhibition qui se tient tous les deux
ans au Bourget je m'en réjouis
pendant que j'étais en charge de
l'énergie nous avons connu deux
événements majeurs qui ont profondément
marqué le contexte de la politique
française et européenne de l'énergie
dans les années 2010
le premier ce qu'on a appelé l'accident
de Fukushima qui survient le 11 mars
2011 et ses conséquences n'oublions pas
mais vous le savez qu'avant d'être un
accident nucléaire ce qu'il devint dans
un second temps il s'agit d'abord d'un
tremblement de terre un séisme de
magnitude 9 au large de la côte est du
Japon qui provoque un tsunami lequel
vient heurter et détruire en partie la
centrale de Fukushima et notamment ses
circuits et son matériel de
refroidissement
il y aurait beaucoup à dire sur cette
accident sur sa gestion et les leçons à
en tirer si vous le souhaitez nous
pourrons en reparler avec Bernard Bigot
je me suis rendu sur place à Fukushima
fin février 2012 je crois même avoir été
le premier membre d'un gouvernement
étranger à être autorisé à me rendre sur
le site et j'en garde évidemment un
souvenir assez marquant
en France et dans la foulée très vite
dans toute l'Union européenne le
gouvernement va saisir l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire en lui demandant de
bien vouloir étudier les leçons à tirer
de l'accident de Fukushima pour nos
centrale et notamment lié les risques
liés à la destruction de matériel de
secours et aux inondations
permettez-moi de rappeler même si c'est
un peu didactique quelques dates qui
montrent ce qu'a été la rapidité de la
réponse française qui était évidemment
très scrutée dans tous les pays
intéressés par la question du nucléaire
civile le 15 mars 2011 soit 4 jours
après l'accident de Fukushima le Premier
ministre François Fillon saisit
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire et lui
demande dès que les données en
provenance du Japon seront évidemment
disponibles de procéder à une revue de
toutes nos centrales
le 21 mars 2011 donc 10 jours après
l'accident je participe à Bruxelles à un
jeu cite conseil extraordinaire des
ministres européens de l'énergie au nom
de la France je porte alors deux
propositions des tests de résistance
certains diront des stress tests
intégrant le retour d'expérience des
événements japonais et mettant
particulièrement l'accent sur quatre
points le risque d'inondation le risque
sismique le risque de perte de
refroidissement notamment par la perte
d'alimentation électrique ainsi que les
mesures permettant de limiter un
éventuel accident grave
deuxième point je plaide aussi pour que
l'Europe adopte les objectifs de sûreté
dit de troisième génération
recommandé par l'association des
autorités de sûreté ouest européennes ce
qu'on appelle WENRA
le Conseil des chefs d'État et le
gouvernement qui se réunit trois jours
après les 24 et 25 mars adoptera pour
l'essentiel les positions françaises
cette revue générale a abouti vous le
savez à la préconisation de travaux
parfois important sur certains des sites
et à des investissements en organisation
et en matériel moteur de moteur de
secours matériel rénové groupe
d'interventions à proximité etc vous
savez cela
il est devenu commun d'affirmer que
Fukushima aura provoqué un coup de froid
sur le nucléaire civil dans le monde
c'est vrai mais ce n'est qu'en partie
vrai la Chine la Russie les États-Unis
la Corée du Sud ou l'Inde non pas que je
sache remise en cause leurs programmes
ou l'essentiel de leur programme et le
Japon pourtant traumatisé à relancer le
sien depuis
au sein de l'Union européenne la
conséquence la plus lourde et la
décision allemande de entre guillemets
sortir du nucléaire annoncé moins de
deux mois après l'accident de Fukushima
par la chancelière Merkel décision
officiellement prise pour des raisons de
sûreté tenant compte aussi de l'émotion
émotion incontestablement réelle suscité
par l'accident en Allemagne et dans
beaucoup de pays
les décisions on le comprend très vite
en réalité prise d'abord pour les
raisons électorales la chancelière
utilise l'accident de Fukushima pour
préparer une éventuelle alliance avec
les Verts qui échouent qui échouent
rapidement je crois en 2013
à l'époque les membres du gouvernement
français ne commentent pas cette
décision car le président Sarkozy sans
doute soucieux de préserver la relation
franco-allemande nous demande de ne pas
le faire mais aujourd'hui on peut la
commenter la décision de la chancelière
Merkel prise sans aucune concertation
avec ses partenaires pas même une
information préalable alors que nos
interconnexions et nos échanges
électriques étaient forts et selon moi
une décision à la fois irrationnelle et
pardonner le mot cynique
elle n'aura fait qu'à croître la
dépendance qui était déjà grande et que
l'on savait déjà grande de l'Allemagne
parce que je vois dans des débats
actuels qu'on suggère qu'on a découvert
la dépendance allemande au gaz russe
depuis l'agression russe en Ukraine mais
c'est faux en 2019 2011 on sait déjà
parfaitement que l'Allemagne est déjà
tributaire du gaz russe et donc ça a cru
cette dépendance et par ricochet celle
de l'Europe au gaz russe l'Allemagne
s'en remettra elle est de loin
l'économie la plus forte d'Europe
je n'ai jamais compris personnellement
pourquoi et comment dans la foulée
l'Allemagne a pu apparaître comme un
modèle de développement énergétique
écologique la réalité que malgré son
fort investissement dans les énergies
renouvelables l'Allemagne est redevenu
très dépendantes évidemment du gaz mais
aussi du charbon et qu'à la fortement
augmenté les prix de son électricité
quant à ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre elles ont de façon optique baissée
temporairement mais uniquement grâce à
la substitution du charbon par le gaz
une autre conséquence qui a mes yeux
aurait été très grave a été évitée et
bizarrement cela est passé je veux dire
largement inaperçu peut-être parce que
nous-mêmes nous Français n'avons pas
cherché à lui donner une publicité qui
aurait pu être contre-productive pour la
filière nucléaire française
je m'explique dès l'accident de
Fukushima et plus encore après la
décision de la chancelière Merkel de
mettre fin à la production d'électricité
nucléaire en Allemagne le commissaire
européen à l'énergie monsieur Huttinger
commissaire de nationalité allemande a
tout fait pour inciter l'Union
européenne à sortir du nucléaire
ce n'était évidemment pas en son pouvoir
des choix de mix énergétique relevant
comme vous le savez des décisions de
chacun de nos pays mais vous imaginez
aisément l'impact qu'aurait-tu à un
moment où l'opinion publique était déjà
fortement troublée l'appel du
commissaire européen à l'énergie à
cesser toute activité nucléaire civile
au sein de l'Union européenne
il préparait le terrain par des
questions faussement ingénues du type
serons-nous capables de sortir du
nucléaire il multipliait les
déclarations à l'emporte-pièce au moment
de Fukushima elle disait à la télévision
le Japon était désormais placé contre
les mains de Dieu certes pour tout
croyants on est toujours entre les mains
de Dieu mais en la circonstance il y
avait une gestion d'un accident grave un
accident majeur et il y avait d'autres
réponses à apporter que celle-ci il
évoquait je cite l'Apocalypse il
contribuait clairement et à mon avis
volontairement à amplifier un climat
anxiogène pour peser sur les opinions
publiques et donc sur les états notre
riposte s'est organisé en deux temps
d'abord lors du conseil des ministres
européens de l'énergie du 21 mars 2011
que je citais je lui ai directement
demandé de cesser ses déclarations et
rappeler les prérogatives respectives de
la Commission et des étapes en frontière
de politique énergétique soutenu en cela
par plusieurs de mes collègues européens
de l'époque dont le Britannique
fortement
je dirais avec force la même chose le 19
mai 2011 quelques semaines plus tard
donc à Prague lors du sixième Forum
européen de l'énergie nucléaire j'ai ici
le texte de mon intervention qui résume
assez bien je crois les positions en
action de la France dit poste Fukushima
et les tiens le tien ce texte à
disposition de votre commission
ensuite plus tard dans la même année
nous avons compris qu'il préparait le
commissaire à nouveau une offensive pour
le Conseil énergie qui était prévu début
2012 et qui s'est finalement tenu à
Bruxelles le 14 février avec évidemment
la valve de l'Élysée et de Matignon
comme le confirme le compte-rendu du
Conseil de politique nucléaire du 8
février 2012 j'ai pris l'initiative
d'inviter quelques jours avant à Paris
les 16 ministres de l'énergie dont les
pays étaient concernés au sein de
l'Union par la production nucléaire
civile cette réunion s'est tenue le 12
février 2012 à Bercy
11 ministres se sont personnellement
déplacés les autres ont bien voulu nous
faire savoir qu'ils étaient solidaires
des orientations de notre action ce qui
fait qu'avec l'accord de mes collègues
que j'ai explicitement demandé pendant
cette réunion du 12 février à Bercy j'ai
plus deux jours après le 14 février 2012
demandez au commissaire Hottinger de
bien vouloir cesser son offensive
anti-nucléaire et de cesser aussi de
plaider pour un partenariat renforcé
avec la Russie il prenait non seulement
un achat accru de gaz russe mais aussi
paradoxe absolu l'achat d'électrons de
source nucléaires aux Russes la centrale
de Kaliningrad
je demande aussi ce jour là au
commissaire et à ceux de mes collègues
européens qui plaident pour une
stratégie principalement axée sur les
énergies renouvelables de bien vouloir
dire la vérité à nos concitoyens
citoyens européens pour les sur les
conséquences d'un recours accru aux
énergies fossiles pour gérer
l'intermittence sur le prix de
l'électricité sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et l'impact pour nos
industries électro-intensibles
le second événement majeur
et la façon dont dans la foulée en
France le cycle électoral et
l'alternance ont conduits à une rupture
de consensus politiques qui avait existé
depuis 1974 même il avait même s'il
avait connu son premier accro avec la
décision du gouvernement Jospin de
fermer super Phénix en 1997
le point culminant de ce cycle est
évidemment la loi dite relative à la
transition énergétique pour la
croissance verte
titre donc qui est déjà en soi tout un
programme de 2015 adopter durant le
mandat du président Hollande loi que
précède et que prépare l'accord verps de
luminance et les fameux 55 ans visant à
limiter à 50 % les l'énergie d'origine
nucléaire
loi selon moi baroque nocive pour la
filière nucléaire qui fixera donc un
objectif de 50% à je cite l'horizon 2025
horizon qui comme tout bon horizon ou
tout mirage c'est ensuite éloigné
jusqu'en 2035 et que le Parlement
vous-même va vous je crois enfin abolir
et peut-être même à celle pourtant
grande de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
à ces étapes préjudiciables à notre
filière nucléaire il faut à mon avis
ajouter la décision prise en 2018
d'arrêter le programme Astrid les
réacteurs dit de quatrième génération à
neutrons rapide et RNR me paraissent
pourtant être le prolongement naturel de
ce que la France s'efforce de faire
depuis le début de son programme
électro-nucléaire à savoir maîtriser de
l'amont à Laval le cycle du nucléaire et
être capable de entre guillemets fermer
le cycle comme disent les experts
le réacteur de quatrième génération
reste le chaînon manquant de notre
programme il permettrait à la fois à la
France d'éliminer l'essentiel des
déchets
issus de la production et d'accroître
son indépendance par rapport à
l'importation d'uranium naturel grâce à
l'utilisation du plutonium jusqu'ici
accumulée les experts estiment que dans
ce cas nous disposerions alors de
milliers d'années de stocks disponibles
j'ai quitté le ministère de l'énergie
comme vous l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure
il y a plus de 10 ans maintenant lorsque
je regarde ce qu'était la forte
puissance du nucléaire civile français
il y a 10 ans et ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui je vous le dis sincèrement
j'ai le sentiment d'un gâchis et même
d'un très grand gâchis
nous n'avons plus le leadership mondial
dans le domaine du nucléaire civil nous
sommes désormais devancés par la Chine
par la Russie par les États-Unis voir la
Corée du Sud et peut-être bientôt l'Inde
nous ne sommes plus en pointes sur le
nucléaire d'avenir nous avons perdu une
partie une partie seulement j'allais
dire heureusement de l'avantage
compétitif que nous procurer pour nos
industriels pour nos entreprises et
évidemment pour nos concitoyens la
robustesse de notre parc nucléaire
à force de dénigrer le nucléaire pour
certains ou pour d'autres d'avoir eu ce
qu'on a appelé le nucléaire honteux
c'est à dire de ne pas oser assumer et
défendre l'un de nos principaux atouts à
force aussi de ne pas créer de
perspectives d'arrêter systématiquement
des projets plutôt que dans soutenir de
se contenter de démanteler au lieu en
même temps de construire bref à force de
ne pas protéger notre patrimoine nous
allons à la fois perdu des compétences
perdus un savoir-faire détourner des
jeunes et notamment de jeunes ingénieurs
d'un secteur dont tout pourtant indique
qu'il jouera encore un rôle majeur dans
le siècle en cours
le GIEC même le GIEC allait-je dire à
lui-même reconnu que le monde ne peut se
passer du nucléaire si l'on veut à la
fois produire l'électricité dans le
monde moderne a besoin et lutter
efficacement contre les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre la France reconnaît
désormais que notre demande
d'électricité va croître fortement dans
les décennies à venir personnellement je
n'en ai jamais douté et je l'ai dit
clairement lorsque j'étais en fonction
c'est aussi ce que le montrer le rapport
il y avait fait allusion monsieur le
Président énergie 2050 pilotée par
Messieurs Percebois et Mandil et que
j'avais commandé en 2011 et qui fut
rendu en 2012
c'est pourquoi j'ai été parfois surpris
par certains scénarios ou scénari à mes
yeux farfelus émis par des autorités
pourtant compétentes je pense notamment
mais pas seulement à RTU car il est
évident que même en faisant de gros
efforts d'économie d'énergie ou de
sobriété nos besoins et usages
électriques ne vont cesser de croître
nous n'aurons pas de véhicule électrique
sans électricité nous n'irons pas vers
la nouvelle révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle et du calcul quantique sans
électricité un grand pays un pays
industriel qui veut le rester et où le
redevenir a besoin d'une base de
production d'électricité stable
commandable entre guillemets ou
pilotable entre guillemets
cela signifie donc à côté de l'or bleu
quelle est l'hydro-électricité que
l'hydroélectricité parce qu'évidemment
Diderot électricité c'est j'allais dire
le bonheur absolu en matière d'énergie
qui a toutes les qualités que l'on peut
espérer mais dont nous tirons en France
déjà très bien parti nos marges de
manœuvre sont donc limitées à côté de
l'électro hydroélectricité seul le
nucléaire et les centrales thermiques au
gaz ou au charbon offre la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le pilotage
nécessaire à l'activité d'un grand pays
or pour de bonnes raisons nous voulons
réduire et à terme nous passer des
sources fossiles
un jour viendra sans doute où les
énergies renouvelables je pense d'abord
au solaire pourront jouer un rôle majeur
dans le mix énergétique d'un pays au
caractéristiques d'une autre mais ce
jour viendra lorsque le stockage massif
de l'électricité nouvelle frontières
toujours annoncée mais pour leur loin
d'être atteinte lorsque ce stockage à
grande échelle sera compensée la grande
faiblesse actuelle des énergies
renouvelables je veux évidemment parler
de leur intermittence
pour conclure sur une note plus
optimiste que le sentiment de gâchis que
j'exprimais il y a un instant je note
avec plaisir que le président Macron a
changé de position concernant le
nucléaire civil en novembre 2018 il
prévoyait la fermeture de 14 réacteurs
nucléaires d'ici 2035 à Belfort en
février 2022 le président Macron a
annoncé la construction de 6 nouveaux
EPR dit EPR 2 et le lancement d'une
étude pour la construction de 8 autres
j'ai vu aussi que le Parlement a été
saisi de projets de loi visant accélérer
les procédures et permettre ainsi à
notre pays de construire plus vite ces
infrastructures énergétiques c'est plus
que bienvenu c'est indispensable le
discours de Belfort si les suivaient des
faits se confient ce que confirmera
j'espère la prochaine programmation
pluriannuelle permettrait une vraie
relance du nucléaire civile en France et
personnellement je m'en réjouis il
manque cependant à mon avis encore
quelques briques à l'édifice car je
crois que nous avons réellement besoin
d'un nouveau plan Messmer un nouveau
plan Messmer à l'échelle de ce que
seront les besoins de la France pour les
30 ans qui viennent
ce plan devrait me semble-t-il comporter
d'abord une programmation de la
construction des nouveaux EPR je pense
que nous devrions viser à retrouver ce
que certains appellent des capacités
excédentaires mais qui sont avant tout
selon moi soit des capacités
exportatrices et Dieu sait que notre
balance commerciale on a bien besoin
soit une capacité de réserve lorsque
pour des raisons programmées ou
inopinées certaines centrales doivent
être mises à l'arrêt
deuxièmement une relance du programme
Astrid de son équivalent c'est-à-dire la
recherche et le développement
d'un démonstrateur de quatrième
génération
troisièmement le développement de petits
réacteurs qui pourraient être bien
adapté si ce n'est à notre pays mais à
coup sûr à d'autres pays qui ont et
auront besoin d'électricité et de plus
en plus à l'avenir de capacité de
dessalement de l'eau de mer
un dernier mot
la France est une puissance moyenne même
si elle conserve un rayonnement
international les tendances des 30 ans
qui viennent ne lui sont guère
favorables
elle était la France la quatrième
économie mondiale il y a 25 ans elle est
aujourd'hui la sixième économie mondiale
elle devrait être dans 25 ans la
huitième économie mondiale ce sont des
faits et des tendances pour le pour ce
qui est des prochains 25 ans on pourrait
être ou pour rester une puissance
mondiale il faut le vouloir et il faut
valoriser ses atouts le nucléaire civil
en est un ou en été il pourrait le
redevenir si on agit vite et fort
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
ses propos liminaires qui sont déjà très
complets
ils vont nécessairement
inspirer un certain nombre de questions
j'en ai j'ai une première question
vraiment d'ordre de contextualisation
vous vous avez évoqué le consensus que
le la question du nucléaire civile a pu
avoir dans le débat de l'État et public
et dans l'opinion publique
à partir de la sortie de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
quel est l'état du débat sur les
questions de façon plus générale
d'énergie
lorsque vous notamment on a beaucoup
expertisé un peu la question de la
Fukushima mais plutôt sur le début du
quinquennat quel est un peu l'état
d'esprit sur ces questions d'énergie
est-ce que c'est un sujet est-ce que
c'est une préoccupation politique
publique ou est-ce que c'est plutôt une
préoccupation accessoire
non non elle n'est absolument pas
accessoire je dirais que pour tout État
moderne tout responsable politique c'est
que l'approvisionnement énergétique et
la sécurité de cette approvisionnement
quelle qu'en soit les sources sont des
fondamentaux économiques donc et le
décret d'attribution qui est qui est le
mien que vous avez rappelé en
introduction le dit très clairement
expressément
alors les
commentaires le niveau
donc ça c'est la base fondamentale et je
vous l'ai dit lorsque je suis reçu
successivement par le président Sarkozy
et le Premier ministre Sion qui au-delà
de mon décret d'attribution me disent ce
qu'ils attendent de moi ces objectifs
organiser la filière nucléaire veillez à
la sécurité de nos approvisionnements
dans tous les domaines c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi je je lance dans la foulée en
je parle de mémoire le comité des métaux
stratégiques pour essayer de veiller à
notre approvisionnement et voir où sont
nos éventuels faiblesses pour ce qu'on
appelle les métostratégiques les terres
rares etc etc donc c'était un peu annexe
par rapport à des énergies pure si je
puis dire mais c'était une source de
préoccupation donc c'est fondamentaux
existent après il y a le débat politique
au sens est-ce que l'opinion publique
est alerté sur les sujets en 2010 c'est
encore relativement serein il y a des
personnes des personnalités hostiles au
nucléaire mais ça ne date pas de 2010
c'est un débat récurrent depuis 20 ans
qui s'est ensuite accentué au moment de
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 et la
de 2015 donc en 2010 il est encore que
j'allais dire maîtriser sous-jacent donc
ça dépend notre préoccupation en
revanche au-delà de
sur les secteurs énergétiques je ne
parle pas de l'industrie je ne parle pas
du numérique ce matin mais sur le
secteur énergétique j'ai eu deux très
grandes préoccupations le nucléaire
évidemment l'accident de Fukushima on y
reviendra peut-être mais aussi on a un
peu oublié c'est une époque où le prix
du baril de pétrole c'est-à-dire flambe
l'image est mauvaise en tout cas crois
de façon extraordinaire il y a un moment
où il est à 150 dollars le le baril et
donc notre préoccupation à ce moment-là
la mienne c'est de tout faire je vais en
Arabie Saoudite je vais au Koweït je
vais aux Émirats etc on essaie d'obtenir
à ce moment-là une espèce de relâchement
par l'augmentation il y a des choses
telles qu'elles sont du nombre de baril
sur le marché pour peser sur les prix à
un moment de façon coordonnée avec les
Américains les Australiens les
Britanniques nous relâchons même entre
guillemets
quelques éléments de nos stocks
stratégiques pour envoyer un signal au
marché et faire chuter un peu
artificiellement les prix ce que nous
avons réussi à faire ce qui fait
qu'ensuite les spéculateurs se sont un
petit peu méfier voilà donc c'est une
préoccupation constante
quotidienne et qui doit être une
préoccupation constante pour un ministre
de l'énergie à mon avis mais dans le
débat public jusqu'à l'accident de
Fukushima et toutes les conséquences que
j'ai évoquées
c'est assez relativement bien maîtrisé
on va beaucoup parler du nucléaire on a
beaucoup parlé du nucléaire dans notre
commission d'enquête mais j'aimerais du
coup poser d'abord une question sur les
autres énergies à ce moment-là vous
l'avez un peu abordé
quel est le regard qui est porté qu'elle
analyse sont faites de la structuration
des marchés des différences peut-être
entre les enjeux sur le gaz sur le
pétrole sur l'électricité
parce que finalement vous êtes ministre
à l'occasion de l'adoption de la loi non
qui vient calquer sur le marché
d'électricité des règles des logiques de
marché qui sont celles qui s'appliquent
sur les autres matières du coup quelle
est la perception de des vulnérabilités
des questions de souveraineté sur les
sur les approvisionnements en gaz et en
pétrole
alors je laisse pour l'instant la reine
je vais être franc avec vous j'ai
préparé une réponse sur l'arène
c'est ce que j'ai compris cela parce que
je sais que vous en avez abondamment
parlé et je m'attendais pas besoin
d'être un grand prospectiviste
est-ce que vous me posiez la question
donc j'ai une j'ai une réponse
pas surtout mais sur ce point là oui je
m'y attend
pour le reste je vous l'ai dit
la préoccupation d'approvisionnement est
constante mais nous avons une
caractéristique en France qui est un
formidable atout et que je veux redire
c'est d'avoir des grandes entreprises
qui assurent la sécurité de notre
emprevisionnement total j'ai des choses
à l'époque devenu Angie et Areva en
matière de d'uranium naturel et à
l'époque aussi de de mine je le redis
parce que on a un débat d'actualité en
ce moment que que je trouve absolument
extraordinaire cette capacité d'auto
flagellation qui ne cesse de me sidérer
on se plaint on pleurniche que Total
fasse de grands bénéfices mais qu'adieu
le plaise c'est une excellente nouvelle
que Total fasse d'énormes bénéfices ça
n'interdit pas et il y a pas besoin de
comment on peut être même un libéral
américain ou un démocrate américain pour
s'interroger sur l'opportunité de taxer
des profits ponctuels liés d'abord à une
politique intelligente de Total qui a
misé sur le GNL et qui en a tiré
parfaitement les les profits dans la
dans la période récente mais est-ce que
on doit regretter que nous ayons trois
majors entre guillemets trois majeurs
dans ce monde énergétique qui assure
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement c'est
une bonne chose que total soit bien
placé c'est une bonne chose que les gens
soient bien soit bien placé donc dans ce
cas là le rôle du ministre de l'Énergie
évidemment ne peut pas être et ne doit
pas prétendre être faire à la place des
acteurs et dans une entreprise majeures
mais de les accompagner éventuellement
de les aider et moi je l'ai fait je suis
allé au Kazakhstan et les dirigeants
d'Areva mon
moi accompagné pour discuter
uranium et mine je suis allé avec
Christophe de Marjorie aux Émirats au
Koweït en Arabie Saoudite si je me je me
souviens bien pour les raisons que je
vous ai indiqué tout à l'heure et pour
parler pétrole
je ne suis pas allé en déplacement avec
Gérard mestralet mais j'avais en
préoccupation permanente le
renouvellement du gaz le ministre
accompagne dit aux politiques locaux
importance stratégiques qu'attache la
France à ce que les entreprises
françaises en charge du sujet obtiennent
le renouvellement d'un certain nombre de
contrats et de concession pour le reste
il y avait la question des énergies
renouvelables
la ma feuille de route était assez
simple on sortait de ce qu'on avait
appelé le Grenelle de l'environnement
qui avait été organisé mise en musique
par Jean-Louis Borloo moi ma feuille de
route elle était assez claire
d'appliquer ce que avait été les
engagements pris par le Président de la
République à l'issue du Grenelle de
l'environnement ce qui nous fait lancer
l'appel d'offres
d'éolien offshore que vous avez cité
tout à l'heure et un certain nombre
d'appels d'offres avec pour
préoccupation permanente là d'essayer de
comment dire d'en profiter ce qui
n'était pas facile
de favoriser l'émergence d'une industrie
française dans un certain nombre de
domaines pour l'éolien offshore c'était
possible pour le solaire et l'éolien
c'était très difficile parce que nous
avions et nous avons toujours un retard
colossal lorsqu'on développe les
énergies c'était le cas avant c'est
toujours le cas aujourd'hui il faut bien
dire pour l'essentiel que nous
favorisons l'importation chinoise donc
il faut avoir ça en permanence en tête
quand on parle du développement des
énergies renouvelables
alors je viendrai tout à l'heure sur des
questions plus précises sur sur
votre action en tant que ministre mais
encore une fois sur des sujets un peu de
perception de l'état du débat public
bon le sentiment c'est que en France et
quand même beaucoup de
volonté d'étayer les faits de définir
des stratégies comment est-ce que ça se
construit au niveau européen vous avez
parlé des des déclarations du
commissaire européen allemand
à l'époque comment est-ce que vous
percevez la construction des décisions
européennes notamment dans dans les
études qui sont conduites et et la
capacité à étayer les scénarios qui sont
suggérés
finalement le mandat qui a été le mien
en tout cas la fonction que j'ai exercée
au niveau européen en matière d'énergie
a été très marquée par l'accident de
Fukushima donc si je simplifie au risque
de caricaturer pour moi ça a été une
bataille permanente
explicite à certains moments
sous-jacente implicite à d'autres
moments avec le commissaire Hunger
avec lequel j'avais des par ailleurs des
des apartés ou des entretiens informés
ils se moquer un peu de moi en disant
quand
on se voyait en aparté il me disait
tiens bonjour voilà le le président des
du syndicat du du nucléaire en France
du nucléaire en Europe bon ce qui était
une façon de dire mais que j'assumais
que j'essayais après
l'accident de Fukushima
de préserver ce qui me paraissait être
un atout français et européen ce qui
fait que évidemment nous avons débattu
d'un certain nombre d'autres sujets la
France avait pris des engagements pour
ce qu'on avait appelé le paquet
énergique climat le développement du
renouvelable etc etc mais les les
Conseils européens de l'énergie des
ministres de l'énergie européen lorsque
j'y étais tourné énormément autour de la
question de Fukushima des tests de
sécurité
postukushima et je vous l'ai dit de la
tentative du commissaire Huttinger
d'amener l'Union européenne vers la
sortie du nucléaire et ça ça a occupé
pas mal de montants et si je veux dire
de mon énergie
et on voit aujourd'hui
l'injonction européenne autour de la
question des interconnexions comment
est-ce que ces sujets là sont traités
voilà début de la décennie 2010
et quels sont les points de fragilité
qui sont alors
identifiés sur ces enjeux de
d'interconnexion j'ai envie de dire
électrique peut-être gasi aussi si je
peux vous suggérer une discrétion oui
sur le gaz
la bataille est entre les partisans de
tel ou tel corridor Nord Stream South
Stream etc des choses que que vous
connaissez et qui en clair
consiste à
comment dire faire ou non de l'Allemagne
à hub gasier ce qu'elle voulait être et
ce que nous Français nous confusion non
pas par une compétition par volonté de
contrecarrer les plans allemands mais
parce que ça nous paraissait créer une
dépendance soit pas créée d'ailleurs je
redis ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure la
dépendance existait déjà mais accroître
une dépendance
au gaz russe
les interconnexions c'était c'est
toujours un sujet majeur la France en a
elle les développer vers le nord le nord
de l'Europe vers le sud aussi pendant
que j'étais en fonction de mémoire on a
déclaré d'utilité publique la liaison
avec l'Espagne qui devait être une
liaison souterraine à travers le
Pyrénées chantier qui qui avait mis
beaucoup de temps mais qu'on a essayé de
pousser de mémoire aussi en développer
nos interconnexions avec
l'Italie bref les interconnexions existé
elle devait être accentuée pour deux
raisons une positive et l'une défensive
si je puis dire ou au sens protectrice
pour la France la France exportée je
crois que ça a été caractéristique
pendant toute ces années sauf si j'ai
bien compris en
2021-2022 sur surtout mais même lorsque
nous étions exportateurs nous dépendions
de ces interconnexions pour la pointe ou
pour un certain nombre de moments
j'imagine que les dirigeants drte où ils
ont dit que ces interconnexions il les
surveillent comme le lait sur le feu
puisque il faut qu'à tout instant
l'offre et la demande se rend compte ce
qui fait qu'on peut être exportateur net
et avoir aussi besoin d'importation
ponctuelle parfois dans la journée donc
oui c'était un souci permanent et
d'ailleurs je crois que le record de
production d'électricité en France
et donc de consommation a été battue
en février 2012 lorsque j'étais en
fonction et je mettais symboliquement
rendu dans les locaux de drte pour
surveiller sur sur leurs écrans ce qui
avait été notre point à ce moment-là
c'est dire que cette préoccupation était
constante à cela venait s'ajouter une
deuxième difficulté qui va s'accroître
les dirigeants RTE vous diraient mieux
que moi que c'est relativement facile
même si cette un investissement lourd
d'assurer des connexions à partir de
je ne sais plus 19 centrales
ou en tout cas 58 réacteurs mais que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de le
faire avec une multitude bientôt des
milliers
le point du fait du développement des
énergies solaires ce qui va coûter
RTE serait capable de le chiffrer
j'imagine moi pas mais ce qu'ils vont ce
qui va être des investissements
colossaux mais déjà à cette époque du
fait de développement de l'énergie
renouvelable de mémoire nous avions
augmenté la production
éolienne par 4 et solaire par son bon on
dirait les détracteurs disaient à juste
titre qu'on partait d'un volume
relativement bas donc x 4 ou par 100
c'est plus facile quand vous partez de
de plus bas mais on savait déjà que nous
allions devoir
investir énormément dans les réseaux de
RTE donc oui c'était une là aussi une
préoccupation permanente
et vous avez dit dans votre propos
luminaire vous avez vu
quelques mots sur sur les questions des
scénarios de consommation énergétique
quels sont-ils et surtout comment
challenger vous leur construction
est-ce que vous anticipez en 2010 des
transferts d'usage ou c'est quelque
chose qui est complètement hors radar
alors non ça des ça n'est pas du tout en
radar puisque les toutes les questions
sur le climat les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre etc font que tout le
monde sait tout le monde dit très fort
que si on veut réduire ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre il va falloir
passer à l'électrique donc quantité de
domaines le véhicule électrique dont on
parle abondamment aujourd'hui c'était
déjà un dossier sur lequel on
travaillait moi je me souviens que
j'avais des discussions
âpres avec les Allemands c'est pas très
haut de gamme en apparence mais c'est
social dans les conséquences sur le type
de prise à trois trous à deux trous des
des recharges électriques parce qu'il
fallait essayer de d'adopter un standard
européen donc c'est ces questions
étaient
permanentes et connu on a connu une
baisse ensuite de l'électricité parce
qu'il y a eu un certain nombre de
d'événements la crise financière de 2008
et ses conséquences etc mais sur sur la
tendance et sur le temps long tout le
monde savait que la consommation
électrique à terme allait s'accroître et
moi quand j'étais secrétaire d'État
notamment chargé de la Prospective
j'avais piloté un exercice dit France
2025 j'ai relu un certain nombre de ses
conclusions elles étaient limpides de ce
point de vue là donc ça n'est pas un
débat qu'on ne découvre dans les années
2020 en 2009-2010 c'est déjà très
présent
du coup comment expliquez-vous
finalement que que RTE ensuite produira
des rapports justifiants un besoin de
d'électricité à la baisse
bon qu'on a auditionné
dirigeants successifs à souligner le
changement majeur de paradigme qu'a
constitué la cop21
modifiant le facteur 4
en objectif de 0 émissions net et
justifie ça pour le coup c'est de la
poésie pour reprendre votre expression
de tout à l'heure c'est une expression
de Nathalie koscius
voilà est-ce que est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui vous semble
un des un des un des dirigeants de RTE
et franchement
si on parle franchement
François Brotte c'est un garçon
intelligent et qui connaît très bien le
secteur de l'énergie
il couvre produit un rapport qui va
jusqu'à
un scénario soyons juste si j'ai bien
compris si je me souviens bien c'est un
scénario parmi les 5 6 7 je ne sais plus
donc on peut pas dire qu'il a centré ce
rapport là-dessus mais sur du 100%
renouvelable ne tient pas la route c'est
absurde c'est grotesque et je suis sûr
qu'il le sait parce qu'encore une fois
il est intelligent et il connaît bien
ses sujets simplement il est j'imagine
dans un contexte politique et il veut
contribuer à donner du crédit à quelque
chose qui ne tient pas la route de toute
façon un scénario c'est relativement
facile vous pouvez
en économie vous faites ce que vous
voulez de ce point de vue là vous dites
si vous fixez un objectif vous voulez
100% de renouvelable personne ne vous
dira jamais c'est totalement impossible
on vous dira c'est possible mais une
série de conditions sur la flexibilité
sur les scénarios alternatifs sur le
prix évidemment sur les émissions
qui peut que ça peut produire etc etc
qui rendent la chose tellement coûteux
qui créent tellement de dégâts que bien
évidemment aucun responsable politique
sérieux ne va aller dans ce sens mais
de façade sur le papier vous pouvez dire
j'ai un scénario à 100% le renouvelable
et puis après vous connaissez mieux que
moi maintenant la donne politique si
vous voulez arriver à un scénario médian
vous avez tout intérêt à avoir un
scénario que vous ne voulez pas dans un
sens un autre que vous ne voulez pas
dans l'autre sens et prétendre aller
vers un juste équilibre être quelqu'un
d'équilibré donc quand RTE fait ses
scénarios je suis persuadé que son
président n'en croit pas un mot
qu'en façade ça lui permet de dire qu'il
a exploré toutes les toutes les toutes
les pistes en tout cas nous c'était
vraiment pas notre cas sur énergie 2050
au fond qu'est-ce que je fais je vois
bien en 2011 ce qui a été la corvée pS
je pense que c'est une piste dangereuse
et une tendance dangereuse pour notre
pays et j'essaie d'apporter ma
contribution en disant
demandons à des experts qui n'ont pas de
cahier des charges parce que le problème
c'est que si vous prenez des gens
réputés pour leur indépendance vous leur
dites enfin plus exactement ils ont un
cahier des charges parce que ce que vous
voulez qu'ils étudient mais vous ne
pouvez pas les orienter sur tel
direction ils tiennent alors
indépendance et ce qui fait c'est ce qui
fait leur crédibilité donc je ne pèse
pas sur les conclusions du rapport perçu
qui eux-mêmes font un certain nombre de
scénarios mais dont la constance
effectivement de dire qu'à leur avis la
demande d'électricité va croître les
usages de l'électricité vont croître et
que par ailleurs il pense qu'il ne faut
fermer aucune centrale et utiliser
l'atout qui est notre nucléaire
justement j'ai été très surpris
finalement de la conjugaison des
conclusions de ce rapport
avec ce que nous ont dit ensuite les
responsables politiques qui vous ont
succédé
qui ont tous finalement
convenu que la décision d'introduire
l'objectif de réduction à 50% de la part
du nucléaire
à horizon 2025 dans la loi
relevait d'un accord politique et non
d'une étude d'impact c'est Manuel Valls
qui a précisé qui avait aucune étude
d'impact sur le sujet
pourtant
le
scénario enfin le rapport énergie 2050
que vous avez commandé étudier assez
précisément cette question est-ce que ce
rapport était disponible ensuite à
l'administration qui vous a succédé
parce que je ne comprends pas que
l'administration qui vous est succédé ne
l'est pas utilisé en étude d'impact pour
un pour un texte
présenté au Parlement
vous avez entièrement raison d'avoir oui
la réponse est oui il était disponible
il est il est toujours chacun peut le
consulter je suis pas allé vérifier sur
internet mais j'imagine qu'on peut qu'on
peut le faire aisément évidemment la
DGEC
lavée toute l'administration de l'avait
à disposition alors est-ce que c'est
est-ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est
une étude d'impact au terme de la loi
pour préparer la loi de 2015 non c'est
pas formellement une étude d'impact et
d'ailleurs son objectif n'était pas de
préparer évidemment la loi de 2015 mais
est-ce que on peut considérer que ça
fait partie des études visant à éclairer
la décision qui finalement a été prise
et qui aurait pu
j'allais dire enrichir la réflexion des
promoteurs de la loi à l'évidence oui
mais sans aller même jusqu'au rapport
énergie 2050 percevoir mon deal la DGEC
a et avait dans ces cartons suffisamment
d'études de scénarios et d'éléments pour
éclairer largement
les promoteurs de cette loi je pense que
ce qu'ils ont fait ils l'ont fait en
connaissance de cause mais ils l'ont
fait vous j'ai vu cette extrait sur les
réseaux sociaux de ce que vous dit
Manuel Valls
il vous dit la vérité je crois et
d'ailleurs il rappelle qu'il le dit sous
serment il le dit franchement tout le
monde sait tout le monde avait compris
que c'était un objectif d'abord
politique d'ailleurs les ça m'a amusé
parce que les les promoteurs de de cette
loi n'ont cessé depuis juste après
l'avoir voté d'ailleurs de rappeler son
caractère non normatif selon eux ce qui
m'a beaucoup amusé parce que j'ai j'ai
fait peu de droit mais j'en ai fait un
peu et je croyais me souvenir que la loi
est dictée des normes posées des normes
c'est-à-dire des règles juridiques qui
s'appliquent partout donc qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire une une loi non normative
qui chie que c'est un horizon
je suis passionné de football et
en football il y a quelque chose qui est
toujours marrant c'est que lorsqu'elle
joueur vient qu'il arrache à moitié la
jambe d'un autre joueur en général histo
vers l'arbitre et il a ce geste vous
savez il montre le ballon d'un art de
dire je l'ai pas fait exprès je je
visais le ballon et balade toute
proportion gardée c'était exactement la
même chose c'est je l'ai pas fait exprès
c'était un objectif c'était un horizon
ça ne veut strictement rien dire ça ça a
provoqué beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts
pour tenir un objectif qui n'était un
qu'un objectif selon moi de pure façade
j'en viens aux enjeux sur les sur les
matières premières peut-être hors
matières directement énergétique
c'est dans vos attributions
est-ce que c'est une préoccupation qui
apparaît nouvelle
sur ces matières là les métaux métaux
rares terres etc
et comment cette préoccupation
apparaît-elle dans dans vos délégations
ministérielles est-ce que ça fait suite
aussi au scénario sur l'évolution des
réseaux sur les énergies renouvelables
ou est-ce que c'est complètement détaché
de cela
une préoccupation nouvelle je ne pense
pas
je pense que mes
prédécesseurs avaient cette
préoccupation en revanche une
préoccupation accentuée je dirais oui
parce qu'on est à l'air du numérique
parce que le développement des énergies
renouvelables le
j'installe à l'époque un certain nombre
de filières industrielles majeur je
crois que ça s'appelle les comités
stratégiques de filières mais je ne me
souviens plus du nom exact je dis je les
installe parce qu'en fait elles ont été
préparées par mon prédécesseur Christian
Estrosi à l'industrie ça arrive souvent
au gouvernement vous inaugurez ou vous
mettez en place des choses que votre
prédécesseur a préparé en général
d'ailleurs ont voulu rendez assez peu
hommage mais moi je le fais c'est
Christian Estrosi qui l'avait préparé
et donc dans toutes ces filières il y
avait la préoccupation de savoir si les
matières premières nécessaires se
ressuscissantes donc je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure on identifie très vite un
certain nombre
je sais pas si on peut appeler ça des
faiblesses en tout cas de points
d'observation majeures
et c'est pour ça que j'installe ce
comité ce commerce je crois d'ailleurs
que mon mon successeur à l'industrie
Arnaud Montebourg là ensuite
prolonger et développer
j'en viens du coup plus spécifiquement à
la filière électronucléaire avec d'abord
la question sur sur la filière vous avez
dit
prendre le dossier et
organiser un comité politique notamment
sur la question de la gouvernance de la
filière
et finalement décidé de positionner EDF
comme chef de fil en gros de trancher le
débat arriva EDF c'est EDF
j'ai envie de dire pourquoi est-ce que
cette décision est pas venue avant vous
avant moi je ne sais pas je peux
répondre pour la partie au moment où
j'arrive et je vous l'ai dit très vite
lors de mes premiers entretiens avec le
président de la République et le Premier
ministre de l'époque il me demande
d'organiser cette filière et de mettre
fin à ce qu'ils estimait une forme de
cacophonie et de tension bon vous le
savez
je n'ai pas pu lire ou regarder toutes
les auditions que auxquelles vous avez
procédé parce que sont nombreuses et
mauvais fallu une semaine de congés je
pense pour pour au moins oui pour pour
tout lire donc j'imagine que vous y êtes
revenu avec les
protagonistes principaux il y a un
problème de fond qui se pose à l'époque
c'est à dire que le
EDF et de fait
considérés comme le chef de cils en tout
cas par les observateurs étrangers quand
on dit le modèle nucléaire français ou
la référence mondiale
cette a EDF que l'on pense parce que
c'est l'opérateur c'est l'architecteur
enseigné etc et en même temps
Areva se développe et sa présidente en
auvergence qui est très médiatique et
qui prend
qui prend de l'espace je ne dis pas de
façon péjorative
encore surnommé
atomique Anne dont beaucoup de colloques
internationaux prend toute sa place et
prétend au-delà de la médiatisation
aller plus loin que son rôle de entre
guillemets sous-traitant
d'EDF et elle
puisque elle négocie des des accords
avec les japonais Mitsubishi pour un
réacteur de 1000 mégawatts
seule ou avec d'autres partenaires
étrangers ordf elle décide d'aller en
Finlande pour pour le Pr donc le
Areva pense que son métier lui permet et
que sa présence internationale lui
permette d'aller plus loin que son rôle
de fournisseur d'une partie importante
des éléments du nucléaire donc il y a
une divergence de fonds sur ce que sont
les cœurs de métiers ou les
diversifications possibles des métiers
et puis après il en est de l'industrie
comme de la politique ou de tous les
groupes humains il y a des affinités ou
non
et pour employer un langage diplomatique
il y avait assez peu d'affinités
heureux Henri Proglio et
anne-louve vergeon et ça ne contribuait
pas à la sérénité de la filière
il y a eu un certain nombre de
conséquences la plus préjudiciable et
probablement la perte de l'appel d'offre
d'Abou Dhabi 2009 si je ne m'abuse mais
vous vérifierez s'il vous plaît la la
date et à partir de là tout le monde
prend conscience que ça ne peut pas
durer comme ça et donc je vous l'ai dit
dans mon propos introductif moi j'essaie
d'abord de façon informelle
du dire si tous les gars du monde
pouvaient se donner la main on pourrait
peut-être faire autrement etc bon on
voit très vite les limites de l'exercice
et ça dépend moi mais le président de la
République et le Premier ministre qui
disent à un moment ça suffit ça aboutira
au départ de d'un auvergence de la
présidence d'Areva et on va mettre un
chef de fil clair
EDF voilà comment les choses se sont
passées
merci bien alors le
du coup votre votre mandat ministériel
est marqué également par
l'avancée progressive
et relative du chantier de flamant ville
et du premier repère construit en France
l'audition de Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
nous a nous a révélé qu'elle avait pu
émettre un certain nombre de doutes
quant à la robustesse du choix de l'EPR
ou en tout cas peut-être à
s'apprécipitation tout en comprenant
bien qu'il fallait à ce moment-là donner
un signal fort à la filière
j'ai conscience qu'on est
plus de 10 ans après qu'on a un certain
nombre de recul sur ce qui s'est passé
au cours du chantier mais est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous avez alors des alertes sur
le déroulement du chantier sur des
choses qui ne vont pas comme il faudrait
qu'elle se déroule pas comme il faudrait
qu'elle se déroule et est-ce que cela
vous remonte
d'abord je voudrais être sûr d'avoir
bien compris la première partie de votre
question ma collègue de l'époque aurait
émis des doutes sur la robustesse non
non elle a elle a
quand on la questionné sur la raison
pour laquelle le nucléaire n'avait
jamais été dans ses délégation elle nous
a expliqué qu'elle avait
émis des doutes sur
la pertinence plutôt du choix de l'EPR
et considérait que peut-être que tout
n'avait pas été suffisamment expertisé
avant de prendre la décision de
construire et pour reprendre ces termes
sans en essayant de pas les déformer
elle nous a dit elle n'était pas contre
le lancement du chantier mais elle
considérait qu'on aurait peut-être pu
attendre deux ans pour être sûr d'avoir
poussé à bout toutes les hypothèses
écoutez je ne sais pas et je redirai
avec attention le compte rendu déjà pour
moi ma gouverne personnelle j'imagine
qu'elle ne faisait pas
référence à des débats qui se restitués
dans le cadre de l'action
gouvernementale
elle faisait plus référence à des débats
qui avaient eu lieu à l'occasion de la
campagne électorale de 2000 c'est 2007
très bien mais moi j'ai une
caractéristique particulière qui n'est
pas passé totalement inaperçu c'est que
je
suis venu tard dans cette campagne
électorale de 2007 donc je peux pas être
notaire de ce qui ont été des
discussions avant
maintenant pour dire les choses
sérieusement et pour être très clair de
votre commission d'enquête ce débat n'a
jamais eu lieu à l'intérieur du
gouvernement ou dans un cadre
officiel du gouvernement pour le passé
et notamment près 2007 je ne peux rien
dire je ne je ne sais pas
pour répondre à la deuxième partie de
votre question
ce dont on était conscient c'était des
difficultés du chantier de flamand ville
du retard que c'était en train de le
prendre et du coup probablement
plus élevé de ce que ce qu'elle est être
ce chantier et moi qui ne suis pas
ingénieur j'avais demandé à des hommes
de l'art de m'expliquer pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui justifiait
cette difficulté etc et c'était très
intéressant je pense que
ce serait bien que vous discutiez
peut-être pas de façon formelle je ne
sais pas ça vous appartient avec des
hommes du du BTP
et qu'il vous disent ce qu'il m'avait
dit à l'époque et je ne saurais pas
traduire scientifiquement la difficulté
particulière de de ce chantier parce que
au fond et on a un peu tendance à
l'oublier aujourd'hui parce que tout le
monde crie arrow sur sur le Pr bon moi
je suis pas l'avocat de l'EPR comme tout
le monde j'ai trouvé
c'est à dire le Pr sur étagère comme
étant le seul réacteur de 3e génération
dont la filière nucléaire disposée au
moment de mon entrée en fonction même
s'il y avait on y reviendra peut-être
deux autres projets de réacteurs de
moyenne puissance un avec les japonais
avec les Chinois développés par par EDF
mais
pourquoi quand même cette préoccupation
et elle est noble cette préoccupation
c'était de dire que même en cas de
d'accident majeur d'accidents très
graves pour reprendre la
classification Inès que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure quel est le pire de l'accident
c'est quand il y a fusion partielle ou
totale du cœur de réacteur et qu'ils
s'enfonce et qui donc il aimait il n'est
plus refroidi il aimait des des de la
radio toxicité bon et la caractéristique
de l'EPR de ce point de vue là c'est de
nous mettre à l'abri de cela parce que
les
récupérateur un corps catcheur en
anglais et il paraît que cela ces
couches successives ces strates
successives c'est très difficile à faire
je crois que les les Chinois taïshagne
ont réussi plus vite que que les
Français à flamment vides mais il paraît
que c'est très compliqué deuxièmement et
ça aussi on l'a oublié ça me ça me
frappe il y a des moments vous savez
dans la vie publique où on ne parle que
d'un sujet et puis on peut après 10 ans
après ou 20 ans après on la complètement
oublié à l'époque on est dans une
période post
attentats du 11 septembre
aux États-Unis qui avait eu lieu une
dizaine d'années auparavant et on ne
parle que de l'hypothèse tout le monde
avait été frappé par ces avions qui qui
vont dans les tours et que ou qui sont
allés heurter le Pentagone et puis celui
abattu donc ça on ne savait pas
finalement quel était que sa cible
réelle et sa destination réelle et aux
États-Unis vous souvenez il y avait eu
un certain nombre d'hypothèses selon
laquelle c'était une potentiellement une
centrale nucléaire qui aurait été l'une
des je n'en sais rien et à l'époque on
se disait il nous faut des réacteurs de
3e génération qui puisse résister même à
une chute de d'aéronef une attaque entre
guillemets par un avion gros porteur etc
etc donc il y avait une forme de
noblesse de je dirais de ce point de vue
là et de précautions élémentaire qui
était de dire même en cas
d'attentatéroïste même en cas de drame
absolu il ne faut pas que que cela
s'échappe alors évidemment le Pr a entre
guillemets dérapé sur le plan des délais
des coûts etc est-ce que pour autant
il mérite tout ce qu'on dit de lui
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je pense que
le fait que la France soit un des rares
pays au monde à considérer maintenant
qu'elle n'installera que des réacteurs
de troisième génération puisque c'est
notre caractéristique personnellement et
pour notre sécurité comme pour la
durabilité de la filière nucléaire je
considère que c'est un bon point
une dernière question en laisser la
parole au rapporteur
donc l'état du de la commande nucléaire
à l'époque où vous êtes ministre c'est
un chantier de Flamanville 3 en cours
un parc à entretenir donc peut-être que
vous pouvez nous dire deux mots
là-dessus et puis la question du
chantier de Penly enfin du projet de
panique plutôt
qu'est-ce qui est déjà avancé sur Pandi
qu'est-ce qui ne l'est pas
et quelle est la stratégie et la raison
pour laquelle ce choix de construction
de de panier est à l'époque engagé
la décision de police est évidemment une
décision qui appartient en propre au
président de la République dans nos
institutions seule un président de la
République peut décider après
concertation évidemment avec les
ministres concernés son administration
de lancer tel ou telle réacteur ça n'est
pas une surprise parce que le comment
dire ça avait failli se faire quelques
années auparavant je pense que c'est
la présidente Chirac en 2004 si je me
souviens bien et prise la décision et à
l'époque Nicolas Sarkozy ministre de
l'économie et des finances de lancer
le Pr a Flamanville et dès ce moment là
l'hypothèse d'un deuxième chantier à
pranly se pose parce que Pony a des
caractéristiques dont je ne me souviens
plus exactement requise pour se faire
et puis pour des raisons diverses
politique probablement mais aussi
rappelez-vous c'était une époque où
beaucoup disaient mais finalement la
filière
productive nucléaire française et ce que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure dans mon propos
excédentaire en gros nous n'en avons pas
besoin nous n'en n'avons pas besoin tout
de suite donc
à l'époque finalement n'a été prise la
décision de lancer uniquement
un réacteur mais je pense que le
Président de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy avait en tête deux
choses d'abord que les dirigeants de DF
disaient et nous disaient en permanence
qu'il était absolument indispensable de
lancer de nouveaux chantiers à la fois
pour remplacer à terme les centrales qui
part hypothèse aurait dû arrêter si la
SN avait décidé qu'il ne pouvait pas
passer des 40 puis des 50 ans vous savez
comment ça fonctionne et à la fois une
décision de principe et puis ensuite une
décision au cas par cas central par
central et peut-être encore plus
pressant à court terme la nécessité de
conserver et de recruter des compétences
parce que c'est ça l'un des grands
drames de la filière française c'est
qu'à force de ne pas construire ce qui
avait construit son parti à la retraite
mais jeunes ingénieurs en plus comme on
a dénigré la filière n'avait pas de
raison particulière de venir certains
d'ailleurs sont partis à l'étranger on
cherche plusieurs apporter leur
expérience à d'autres opérateurs et on
s'est trouvé fort démuni vous avez cité
un certain nombre de chantiers c'était
une époque alors évidemment Fukushima a
mis un arrêt provisoire sur un certain
nombre de dossiers mais c'était une
époque où beaucoup beaucoup de pays
envisagés ou demander ou disait
envisager de lancer des programmes
nucléaires on parlait de l'Afrique du
Sud on parlait de la Jordanie même si ce
projet qui était discuté contestés si je
puis dire l'Arabie Saoudite très
important
s'apprêtait théoriquement à lancer ce
qui aurait été l'un des plus gros appels
d'offres mondiaux il y avait beaucoup de
projets ils ont été provisoirement gelés
et puis ensuite un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont été relancés donc il n'y
a il n'y a jamais il y a toujours eu des
j'allais dire du pain sur la planche
pour les les industriels Fukushima
ayant notamment en Europe je dis
notamment en Europe parce que ailleurs
c'est plus subtil et plus diffus des
Chinois n'ont rien arrêté c'est c'était
flagrant
les ruches non plus
il y a il y a toujours eu des projets de
chantier
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre pour ces premiers
éléments justement puisqu'on parlait de
l'état de la filière nucléaire je vais
je vais commencer par là pour vous
redemander en termes de compétences de
savoir-faire de maîtrise industrielle
dans quel état vous trouvez la filière
nucléaire française à votre arrivée au
responsabilités en 2010
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure elle elle
passe pour être un outil de grande
qualité
il y a des doutes
le focaliser notamment sur le Pr à
l'intérieur même de la filière nucléaire
certains s'opposent la question de sa
taille est-ce qu'il n'est pas trop
important d'ailleurs elle a été si je me
souviens bien progressivement réduite
puisque le Pr initial si je puis dire
aurait pu aller jusqu'à 1750 ou 1800
mégawatts et finalement il est il a été
ramené autour de sous votre contrôle de
mégawatts il y a d'un point de vue
j'allais dire marketing mais je sais pas
si le terme est approprié ici en termes
de gamme
beaucoup de membres de cette filière qui
disent qu'il nous manque et il nous
manque toujours c'est vrai
dans les produits offerts par la filière
nucléaire française un réacteur de
moyenne gamme autour de
avec Mitsubishi au Japon et c'est ce que
EDF ces forces de faire avec les Chinois
un des deux opérateurs de mémoire cgpn
pour pour en développer pour le reste
sont cocorico excessif nous sommes
considérés à l'extérieur et nous
considérons nous-mêmes en France que
nous avons une une filière de très haut
niveau
je vous remercie quid des compétences au
sein d'EDF est-ce que EDF vous fait
remonter des inquiétudes à votre arrivée
au responsabilités sur sa capacité à
assurer la maintenance et à préparer la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs ou
est-ce que à l'avenant de ce que vous
venez de dire finalement la situation
est encore bonne ou très bonne
assurer la maintenance non ça fait
partie des des fondamentaux si je puis
dire la France je disais tout à l'heure
à tous les tous les échelons tous les
acteurs que ce soit le gouvernement
l'opérateur EDF l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire n'ont jamais transigé avec les
questions de sûreté et de et de
maintenance elles ont toujours été mises
au dessus d'un certain nombre d'autres
objectifs donc non si
EDF nous avait alerté sur le fait
qu'elle n'était pas en situation
d'assurée là maintenant je peux vous
dire que ça aurait été alerte rouge et
général en revanche que EDF nous est
alerté sur les difficultés qu'elle avait
à recruter des jeunes des jeunes
ingénieurs ou des ou des jeunes de
qualité pour une filière qui ne
construisait plus de réacteurs
depuis qui était dénigré par une partie
de l'opinion publique oui et c'est
pourquoi je disais que lorsque
j'installe le comité stratégique de de
filière au Creusot en juillet 2011 l'un
des trois chantiers que nous mettons sur
la table cette les compétences et la
formation avec des groupes de travail de
des vrais groupes de travail c'est pas
simplement pour le communiquer ou pour
la façade qui se penche sur le sujet et
d'ailleurs très vite le ce groupe de
travail dit qu'il ne faut pas réserver
ou limiter cette étude à la filière
elle-même au sens des salariés des
grandes entreprises concernées mais
qu'il faut l'élargir très vite à la
question de la sous-traitance et c'est
pourquoi le deuxième
comité le deuxième conseil de filières
nucléaire auquel je participe puisque
j'aurais participé finalement à j'en ai
mis en place et puis ensuite le second
j'y ai participer
portent sur la sous-traitance donc oui
c'était une préoccupation naissante on
n'était pas évidemment pas dans la
situation de DF 10 ans après mais à
l'époque c'était une préoccupation
naissante et exprimée oui
et donc votre analyse c'est que
finalement au début des années 2010 la
préoccupation commençait à émerger mais
la situation restait gérable et que
c'est la succession de l'accident de
Fukushima puis
de la présentation politique et des
décisions politiques futures qui ont
conduit à cette perte de compétences
moi je ne parlerai pas de perte de enfin
oui pardon
de compétences avec un S d'accord vous
voyez excusez-moi je croyais que vous
dire perte de compétences de la filière
au sens de
ok oui alors si c'est avec un S
c'est-à-dire deux talons de possibilités
de recrutement etc oui de de toute
évidence
c'est normal que de jeunes ingénieurs
ou de jeunes techniciens etc veuille
aller vers des secteurs qu'ils estiment
porteurs
et qu'on et qu'en plus l'opinion
publique ne dénigre pas
[Musique]
on est dans un monde particulier on
disait tout à l'heure
que Total
NJ participe de notre indépendance
énergétique ou de notre
ou contribue à faire que nous sommes
moins dépendants sur le plan énergétique
et en même temps qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
les veut pas sponsor de
des Jeux olympiques de de l'année
prochaine on les dénigre en permanence
donc qui sont sponsors de tous les
événements sportifs un peu partout dans
le monde vous les voyez à la télé pour
ceux qui aiment ces sports mais pas en
France sur le plateau de Saclay j'ai vu
que un certain nombre de d'étudiants
refusés l'implantation de tel ou tel
grandes entreprises
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
dans ma dans ma conclusion si on veut ce
flageller en permanence si on veut
s'autodénigrer en permanence il faut pas
être ensuite surpris par les effets dont
on chéri les causes
nous avons un problème avec notre
industrie nous avons un problème avec
notre énergie nous avons des atouts que
nous nous acharnons à érauder et après
on se plaint soit du prix de
l'électricité soit de d'une forme de
dépendance pour qu'on arrête d'être
schizophrène et il faut un peu de
cohérence c'est vrai pour la politique
énergétique mais c'est vrai pour la
politique tout court
mais je reviens tout de même une
dernière fois sur la question des
compétences et de la décennie 2000 2010
parce que vous avez été munitions de
l'industrie et vous connaissez très bien
le domaine industriel est-ce que c'est
quand même pas un peu étonnant que une
entreprise comme EDF pendant une toute
une décennie de 2000 et 2010 et malgré
la décision
l'annonce de la décision de construire
un nouvel EPR puis en plus la
possibilité d'en construire un autre
apolly finalement et une préoccupation
certes qui émerge pour les compétences
mais qui ne soient pas visiblement
davantage prise en compte ou traité
puisque en creux c'est le comité
stratégique de filière que qui se met en
place sous votre sous vos
responsabilités qui vient commencer à
poser un certain nombre de jalons en
matière de recrutement de compétences
d'attractivité ce sont les réflexions
qu'il y a auditionnait hier on
auditionnait hier monsieur Machenaud qui
était en charge du parc à partir de 2010
qui expliquait aussi les les mesures
qu'il prend pour renforcer
l'attractivité et recruter à partir de
2010 est-ce qu'il n'y a pas dans cette
décennie 2000 une forme de de situation
dans laquelle def se reposerait sur ses
lauriers en termes de capacité à avoir
construit son parc et de d'avoir les
talents ou les compétences disponibles
sans anticiper les prochaines années
oui je sincèrement je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question qui relève de
la Direction de d'EDF et de sa politique
de ressources humaines
en revanche je veux atténuer
l'impression que j'ai pu vous donner je
ne veux pas suggérer que ce comité
stratégique de filière c'est emparé ou
ce soit emparé du sujet que d'autres
n'auraient pas traité jusque là c'est
justement parce que ça émane de tous les
acteurs et notamment le DF que nous
essayons de le traiter de façon
collective
l'impression que que j'ai à l'époque où
je discute avec Henri Proglio qui était
président d'EDF c'est qu'il est
conscient de cela et que lui-même et ses
équipes mettent
ce qui me ditette tout en oeuvre pour
essayer de
s'y préparer maintenant qu'elle audit de
ce qui a été fait
pourrait être fait aujourd'hui
sincèrement je ne sais pas
je vous remercie forcément pour la
robustesse de la filière au-delà des
compétences et à une dimension très
importante qui est celle de sa capacité
financière à investir à anticiper le
futur il y a donc bien sûr la question
du prix de l'énergie et du prix de
l'électricité on a auditionné monsieur
gadoneix qui nous a expliqué que pendant
son mandat donc de 2004 à 2009 sauf
erreur 2004 pardon
de 2004 à 2009 sauf erreur ça vous
paraît raisonnable je crois que c'est ça
il a sans cesse alerté les pouvoirs
publics sur les prix de l'électricité
qui serait trop bas et qui ne
permettrait pas à EDF avec la
maintenance le besoin d'investissement
sur le moyen et sur le long terme
de d'assurer ces missions est-ce que
lorsque vous arrivez au responsabilités
dans vos premiers échanges avec
l'énergéticien avec la filière la
question du prix de l'électricité je
viendrai après au marché européen même
si c'est très lié la question du niveau
des prix se pose et se révèle comme une
inquiétude est-ce que vous au service
vous font remonter des analyses dans ce
sens c'est à dire que les prix aurait
été trop bas pour que la filière
industrielle qui est derrière puisse
vivre et se développer ou est-ce qu'au
contraire c'est pas une analyse qui est
partagée par vos services et donc par
vous même
sincèrement je pense que
rétrospectivement
on peut dresser le constat que vous
faites c'est à dire que si je nous fais
un reproche
collectivement tout gouvernement
successifs confondus c'est probablement
d'avoir
prélevé trop de dividendes à l'époque où
EDF était très en forme financièrement
ça arrange toujours le ministre du
Budget et la France n'a pas été souvent
en position de négliger des recettes
complémentaires pour équilibrer son
budget et donc
j'imagine que les ministres de
l'économie et des finances successives
je parle encore une fois sur une période
longue tout gouvernement confondu ont
demandé à l'Agence des participations de
l'État et donc à EDF de lui verser des
dividendes à l'état important
donc avec le recul et quand on voit ce
que ont été les les événements des
derniers mois et donc l'arrêt d'un
certain nombre de centrales pour des
raisons dites de
corrosion sous
pression
peut-être que qu'il y a eu je ne sais
pas vous avez auditionné des personnes
compétentes peut-être qu'il a eu un
qu'il y a eu un manque de
maintenance prévisionnel prédictive je
ne sais pas quel est le bon adjectif
pour la formule sur l'instant pour
répondre à votre question en tout cas
pour la part qui me concerne non ce dont
me parle en riproglio lorsque
j'arrive au ministère de l'énergie c'est
du fameux prix de la reine donc
j'imagine que nous allons parler à un
moment mais sur la tendance des prix de
façon globale non il ne m'en parle pas
alors maintenant quand vous êtes
président de l'EDF vous ne parlez pas
que au ministre de l'Énergie vous avez
accès aux présidents de la République au
Premier ministre est-ce que le président
de l'époque
moi c'est auprès de moi c'est focalisé
sur le prix de la reine mais que à
d'autres il a parlé en tendance des prix
c'est possible mais pour la part qui me
revient
la discussion avec Henri Proglio quand
j'arrive en fonction mon premier
entretien avec lui me parle du prix de
la rénoie
alors
Vincent Vincent Decker qui doit partir
et puis rapporteur reprendre à ces
questions après oui merci beaucoup une
question sur l'hydraulique je
m'interrogeais de savoir si à cette
période déjà dans les discussions avec
vos homologues européens et des la
question de l'ouverture du marché était
une
question fondamentale et si oui qu'elles
étaient les positions des uns et des
autres
on en parlait comme d'un privilège donné
par la nature
à certains
qui est qui était très bien doté pour
quelques-uns
très peu doté pour l'autre et nous qui
avions de mémoire de l'ordre de 10% de
notre électricité de d'origine
hydraulique tout le monde aurait voulu
être pas la Norvège par exemple ou le
Canada pour sur un autre
continent donc oui le nous parlions
hydroélectricité mais pas de façon
je dirais général comme étant une
question qui se posait à chacun d'entre
nous c'est à dire comment en tirer le
mieux parti parce que pour les raisons
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est la
source
d'énergie idéale et d'énergie
d'électricité
il y avait déjà des demandes très fortes
de certains partenaires de d'arriver à
une ouverture totale
de certains partenaires je ne sais pas
de la commission oui parce que ça
faisait partie des engagements
successifs que nous que nous avions
souscrit depuis
1996 et par un certain nombre de textes
que je rappellerai peut-être lorsqu'on
parlera de la reine mais oui
non non pas que j'y tienne
on peut payer échapper avec grand
plaisir mais je connais votre
préoccupation et simplement donc oui la
Commission le souhaitait et parlons
franchement nous on traînait des pieds
parce que on avait aucune aucune envie
de remettre en cause nos contrats de
concession c'est un peu notre
caractéristique quand on passe des
compromis avec nos partenaires et avec
la commission pour des sur des sujets
que nous ne souhaitons pas profondément
mais qu'on accepte parce que on a
souscrit à des engagements et parce que
ce sont des compromis sur lesquels nous
nous obtenons d'autres choses ou nous
réservons un certain nombre de points
que nous souhaitons par exemple le
monopole nucléaire de fait de DF en
France donc on accepte à
mot mesurer si je puis dire et puis
ensuite on trade un peu les pieds on
impose notre inertie pour la mise en
œuvre oui c'est vrai
je reprends donc justement sur le sujet
tant attendu mais simplement avant pour
avoir le contexte
puisque on a parlé à l'instant des
concessions le contexte des discussions
entre la Commission européenne et la
France vous en avez parlé sur les
dimensions nucléaires comment est-ce que
vous ministre de l'Industrie
vous appréhendez les relations avec le
Commissaire européen en charge avec le
président de la République le Premier
ministre est-ce qu'il y a des lignes
rouges en termes de d'ouverture du
marché européen de tarifs et est-ce que
vous des discussions se concluent dans
une situation vous avez l'impression
d'avoir tenu des lignes qui vous
paraissaient un dépassables ou est-ce
qu'au contraire vous avez eu
l'impression sur certains points ou de
la même de la reine de devoir accepter
des positions qui n'étaient pas les
vôtres au départ et qui vous semblaient
potentiellement dommageable à
l'industrie française
non moi je n'ai pas eu à le faire non
pas parce que j'aurais été plus
plus fort que que les autres mais
simplement parce que lorsque j'arrive au
ministère de l'Énergie
Jean-Louis Borloo a déjà fait le
l'essentiel de la partie la plus
difficile du job si je puis dire c'est à
dire que il a dû
négocier alors que nous étions sous deux
contentieux sous l'impact de deux
contentieux ouverts par la Commission
un compromis un arrangement qui
finalement c'est appelé la reine et donc
c'est comme ça qu'on suit il porte la
première lecture de la loi devant le
Parlement lorsque j'arrive moi en
novembre 2010 à l'énergie l'essentiel de
ces discussions c'est pas l'essentiel la
totalité de ces discussions a eu lieu il
y a eu un compromis trouvé avec la
Commission et c'est au Parlement dans
décidé donc moi je porte la deuxième la
deuxième lecture donc pour répondre à
votre question non il n'y a pas eu dans
un autre sujet que nous avait sur un
autre sujet que nous avons abordé la
ligne rouge oui c'est que que le
commissaire de l'énergie cette fois-ci
tinger ne vienne pas
plaider pour la sortie du nucléaire au
sein de de l'Union et donc oui le
président de la République public à
l'époque me demande régulièrement le
Premier ministre aussi d'ailleurs de lui
rendre compte des discussions à
Bruxelles et de ce que je pressens être
ce que prépare le la Commission et le
commissaire routineur
le sujet de vigilance à l'époque il est
là justement j'en profite pour vous
poser une question incidente c'est
évidemment notre commission ne cherche
pas de bouc émissaire mais ça fait quand
même plusieurs fois que vous évoquez le
commissaire européen Huttinger quels
étaient selon vous les motifs et les
causes qui présidaient à ces positions
visiblement assez opposées
à la situation industrielle française en
matière énergétique et en particulier
nucléaire sachant que là si vous parlez
bien des discussions qui ont lieu en à
l'automne 2010 et au début de la fin de
l'automne début de l'hiver il s'agit
évidemment pas de discussion qui ont
lieu une fois que l'accident nucléaire
de Fukushima a lieu c'est à dire qu'il y
a toute la partie qui relève du moment
où le commissaire rotinger parle
d'apocalypse Fukushima vous avez repris
ses propos indiquent de manière assez
véhémente et catastrophiste que
l'ensemble des réacteurs sur le sol
européen serait en danger etc mais même
avant en fait avant même ceux-là il
semble y avoir des déclarations assez
fortes et des échanges assezvements
est-ce que vous confirmez et à quoi vous
les attribuez
vous savez comme comme souvent politique
il y a une part de conviction et une
part d'habileté
la conviction
du commissaire Huttinger et peut-être
d'autres membres de de la commission
c'est qu'il n'est pas favorable qu'il
n'aime pas je dirais
le combo français
monopole nucléaire puissance d'EDF etc
qui ne le croient pas
comment dire adapter à la situation
européenne et qu'il est
il est très allemand sur la ligne de
pente vers les énergies renouvelables
etc donc il y a chez lui pour ne pas
faire de mauvais procès une part de
conviction et la part d'habileté c'est
qu'après la sortie allemande du
nucléaire je pense qu'il il est
sincèrement persuadé
que l'Allemagne va entraîner dans la
foulée beaucoup de pays finalement peu
mais il y en aura eu quelques-uns après
l'Allemagne mais peu et que deuxième et
que donc il veut en tirer un bénéfice
politique et que comme beaucoup de
commissaires européens vous savez un
commissaire européen ça n'oblige jamais
sa nationalité et il se dit qu'il peut
peut-être revenir en politique dans son
pays et qu'auquel cas il faut être bien
placé pour pour se faire et donc on voit
la ligne de pente allemande et je pense
qu'à ce moment-là le commissaire
rotinger se verrait bien jouer un rôle
majeur je ne sais pas lequel en
Allemagne de façon plus générale et je
pense que c'est un sujet de réflexion
pour nous Français
l'Allemagne a une position de force au
sein de l'Union européenne
elle elle l'a par sa position économique
et l'économie ça compte au sein de
l'Union européenne elle a par la
cohérence
sur le nucléaire il y a eu un virage
subi mais sinon si vous regardez les
lignes de force de la politique
allemande il y a une grande cohérence
sur longue durée ce qui fait que quand à
Bruxelles vous tapez sur le même clou
pendant longtemps évidemment au bout
d'un moment ça ça marche
ça apporte ses résultats et ensuite ces
résultats financiers et sont
relativement faibles endettement si je
peux dire je parle sur votre contrôle
mais je pense que le la dette allemande
doit être aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 70%
du PIB elle était inférieure il y a 10
ans ça passe pour le bon élève ça passe
pour l'élève sérieux sur lesquels nous
pouvons compter alors que nous on va
dire que nous français on a une image
plus contrastée de ce point de vue là
qu'on fait de belles déclarations mais
que les résultats ne suivent pas
toujours etc donc au moment où moi je
fréquente pour mes fonctions les
couloirs de Bruxelles disons le
franchement ceux qui sont pris très au
sérieux
ce sont les Allemands et les
Britanniques et nous il faut
en permanence même si on a bénéficié
il y a encore des effets qu'on qu'on
quand je suis
quand j'arrive à l'énergie du fait que
le rôle personnel du président Sarkozy
pour la gestion de la crise financière
de de 2008 a marqué les esprits donc sur
ce point là on en bénéficie mais ça
c'est pas le quotidien de Bruxelles
je vous remercie et donc entre
en vigueur la loi va rentrer en vigueur
la loi dit non mais voter le 7 décembre
2010 qui prévoit donc l'accès régulier
et la possibilité va l'obligation pour
EDF de proposer à 42 euros de mégawh
pour l'équivalent à peu près de 1/4 de
sa production annuelle de l'électricité
peut-être une question de contexte
puisqu'on a auditionné les responsables
de l'administration de l'époque qui
présente une vision un peu contrastée
par rapport à celle de DF sur le tarif
lui-même et donc je
commence par ça c'est peut-être un peu
le petit bout de la Hornet mais je
commence par ça parce que les services
de l'époque nous disent finalement 42
euros du mégawattheure c'était et ça
correspondait à nos calculs en termes de
coût complet pour EDF en y ajoutant même
la part de travaux nécessaires dû aux
audits à l'audit post Fukushima donc
plutôt 9 et 42 avec
en intégrant ce travaux là et EDF semble
nous dire y compris à l'époque et dès
cette époque au-delà même de la
potentielle actualisation par la suite
que finalement non ça ne reflétait déjà
pas les coûts est-ce que cette
discussion a eu lieu est-ce que vous
êtes retrouvés dans votre bureau de
ministre de l'Industrie au moins par la
suite même si le principe avait été acté
avec d'un côté EDF et de l'autre de vos
services qui n'étaient pas tout à fait
d'accord ou est-ce que ça s'est passé
autrement
c'est patio autrement mais si vous
voulez bien je vais pas faire semblant
et je vous l'ai déjà dit j'ai préparé
sur la reine parce que j'ai compris ce
qui ont été vos débats une réponse je
crois assez complète en tout cas qui
correspond à ma vision qui intègre la
réponse à votre question si vous estimez
que ensuite que je n'y ai pas
suffisamment répondu je peux y répondre
de façon plus plus détaillée
je disais donc j'ai compris que votre
commission avait abondamment débattu de
ce mécanisme et que vous lui avez prêté
une importance ou un certain nombre de
vos interlocuteurs lui ont prêté une
importance et une responsabilité qu'à
mon avis il ne mérite probablement pas
mais qui a c'est vrai un avantage
selon moi c'est un bouquet mystère tout
désigné
si on dit de but en blanc à quelqu'un
l'état obligé d'EDF à vendre à ses
concurrents 25% de son électricité et
que si vous ajoutez en plus
cette
c'est à un prix bradé ce qui est faux on
y reviendra c'est normal que ça fasse
sursauter ça à la vente un avantage
c'est simple et c'est très efficace
est-ce que pour autant c'est vrai je ne
crois pas
quiconque veut bien regarder
objectivement l'effet et prendre le
temps de relire la loi norme ce que je
vais faire si vous le voulez bien avec
vous sur certains extraits tout à
l'heure
et ce qu'elle dit exactement cette loi
norme ce n'est pas si simple je vais
revenir d'un mot d'un point de vue
politique si on critique la reine
critique disons-le honnêtement le
dernier wagon du train
car la locomotive et tous les premiers
wagons ce sont les politiques de
libéralisation et d'ouverture des
marchés mise en oeuvre partout les
gouvernements successifs de la directive
de 96 que j'ai évoquais tout à l'heure à
la loi de 2000 sur le service public de
l'électricité loi dite de transposition
du Conseil européen de Barcelone en mars
2002 à la directive de 2003 qui rend la
totalité des consommateurs éligibles aux
offres de marché au premier juillet 2007
1er juillet 2007 c'est pour ça que
Jean-Louis Borloo est obligé de s'en
occuper alors cette continuité peut
évidemment être discuté ou réévalué elle
a abouti en France à la séparation vous
le savez mieux que moi des activités de
production de transport et de
distribution qui était jusque là le
monopole d'EDF il peut y avoir des
débats comme chaque fois qu'il s'agit
d'une commodité essentielle d'un bien
public
sur le bien fondé de la mesure les
économistes débattent et à mon avis des
patrons encore longtemps pour ce type de
bien des avantages et des inconvénients
respectifs du monopole de l'ouverture à
la concurrence voir de ce qu'on appelle
les oligopoles réguliers mais en
2007-2008 quand Jean-Louis Borloo hérite
de ce dossier il se trouve à une face à
une situation compliquée et j'imagine
qu'il vous la rappelez je dis j'imagine
qu'il vous la rappelez parce que
malheureusement je n'ai pas pu retrouver
le texte de sa de son intervention la
Commission européenne avait alors ouvert
deux procédures contentieuses contre la
France une pour défaut de transcription
de la directive la seconde pour ce qu'on
la commission appelle des aides d'État
avec à la clé un risque lourd on parlait
de milliards d'euros voire de dizaines
de milliards d'euros pour l'industrie
française enfin il existait un
dispositif provisoire ce qu'on appelait
le tartame à l'époque
dispositif protecteur dont nous étions
obligés de sortir avec l'aide de la
Commission champsor et des services de
l'État Jean-Louis Borloo a imaginé ce
dispositif transitoire et je pense moins
qu'il a bien agi il a porté la loi norme
devant le Parlement et en arrivant à
Bercy en novembre 2010 j'ai dû en
assumer immédiatement la deuxième
lecture et je l'assume totalement
évaluons ce dispositif en 2017 la Cour
des comptes le qualifie de dispositif de
compromis et c'est vrai c'est un
compromis je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure entre des exigences
contradictoires compromis avec nos
partenaires européens et compromis avec
la Commission et je vous ai dit aussi
nous avons fait ce que tous les
gouvernements français font dans quand
ils souscrivent un engagement européen
qui ouvre la concurrence et qu'on n'est
pas vraiment convaincu une libération
contrôlée par étape avec un point majeur
qu'un certain nombre de ceux qui
critiquent oublient c'est que le
monopole de fait de DF sur la production
d'électricité nucléaire qui était une
grande préoccupation pour nous a été
maintenue donc une libéralisation
contrôlée et des instruments de
protection et de régulation
et il faut ajouter j'ai l'impression que
tout le monde l'a oublié que beaucoup
d'experts pensaient à l'époque qu'au
fond cette ouverture des marchés que DF
grâce à sa puissance installée grâce au
prix marginal très compétitif du parc
nucléaire pouvait être
l'un des grands gagnants du haut si je
peux dire libéralisation interconnexion
qui s'installaient et je crois que si on
regarde sur une période longue sur une
dizaine d'années et pas sur la dizaine
de mois où la vingtaine de mois
globalement EDF a tiré parti de cette
ouverture puisque nous avons largement
vendu notre électricité en Europe le
débat public en 2010 vous l'avez rappelé
c'était cristallisé sur le prix de la
reine et moi je me souviens avoir dit en
séance au députés qui tenait absolument
à le connaître immédiatement parce qu'il
y avait la loi et on disait que c'était
par arrêté que nous allions fixé le prix
de la reine et en séance c'était comme
dans Molière le poumon le poumon là
c'était le prix de la reine le prix de
le prix de la reine et on me demandait
en permanence mais il y avait même des
députés qui disaient il faudrait
suspendre la séance si le si le ministre
ne nous donne pas immédiatement le prix
de la reine et moi je leur répondais
mais il y a quelque chose que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous focalisez
sur le prix de l'année N alors que vous
avez vous-même député veiller à ce que
ce prix soit révisé tous les ans
pourquoi cette focalisation sur le prix
de l'année 2011 pour quelques mois et
1er janvier 2012 ensuite il nous avions
demandé à nouveau vous l'avez rappelé à
la commission Champsaur et une nouvelle
commission champ de sang si je puis dire
de nous faire des propositions et comme
vous l'avez souligné elle a fait elle
avait le fait proposer une grille une
fourchette de 38 à 40 euros une
suggestion un point moyen à 39 euros
je rappelle que la demande de ce qu'on
appelait alors les alternatives les
nouveaux entrants étaient entre 32 et 35
euros
le mégawattheure le président de DF nous
disait en tout cas me disait lorsque je
l'ai vu sur ce sujet que selon lui ça ne
pouvait pas être inférieur à 40 et que
finalement j'ai finalement signé vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure un arrêté à
42 euros quand je dis j'ai
signé évidemment après arbitrage du
président et du Premier ministre je me
souviens aussi des réactions de l'époque
qui était bien éloignés de ce que l'on
entend aujourd'hui
dans les commentaires quand est sorti
l'arrêté que j'avais signé le prix était
supposé être je cite un cadeau fait à
EDF on était à contre-courant par
rapport à ce que j'entends aujourd'hui
ce que moi je devais me défendre de
n'avoir pas fait un cadeau à EDF
le la plupart des alternatives
c'était dit choqué par ce prix il se
disait déçu GDF Suez l'a dit
explicitement je puisse essayer une
déclaration de son président ou un
communiqué mais je suis déçu par le prix
de la reine
comme je vous ai dit j'ai compris que
vous en aviez beaucoup parlé je me suis
amusé à relire la loi norme pas amuser
c'est excessif un amusement relatif si
on pousse dans mère tranchement je peux
en trouver d'autres mais j'ai quand même
relu la loi
elle précise d'entrer qu'il est mis en
place à titre transitoire un accès
régulé et limité à l'électricité
nucléaire historique et que ce
dispositif doit s'assurer au 31 décembre
2025 le même article 1 stipule que l'on
peut suspendre ce dispositif en cas de
circonstance exceptionnelle affectant
les centrales
paragraphe 7 de ce même article 1 il est
précisé que le prix de la reine est fixé
transitoirement pour trois ans et qu'un
fin d'assurer une juste rémunération
Électricité de France le prix réexaminé
chaque année j'insiste réexaminer chaque
année tient compte de l'addition de la
rémunération des capitaux des coûts
d'exploitation des coûts des
investissements de maintenance ou
nécessaires à l'extension de la durée de
l'autorisation d'exploitation je relis
parce que j'entends en permanence que la
reine ne le prévoit pas si les
investissements de maintenance ou
nécessaires à la durée de l'autorisation
donc les 40 ans le grand carénage pour
reprendre l'expression des exploitants
sont explicitement prévues dans la loi
enfin découper visionnelles liés à la
gestion durable des matières et déchets
radioactifs le paragraphe 8 de l'article
1 indique qu'avant le 31 décembre 2015
puis tous les 5 ans le gouvernement doit
présenter au Parlement un rapport
d'évaluation des dispositif évaluant je
résume
ce ne sont pas toujours les termes
exacts de la loi mais je résume pour
faire court sa mise en oeuvre son impact
sur la concurrence son impact sur le
fonctionnement du marché de gros la
justice son impact sur la conclusion de
contrat de gré à gré et le cas échéant
propose des modalités de fin du
dispositif propose le cas échéant des
adaptations du dispositif propose
d'associer les acteurs intéressés aux
investissements de la prolongation de la
durée de vie des centrales nucléaires
propose enfin le cas échéant de mettre
en place un dispositif spécifique
permettant de garantir la constitution
de moyens financiers appropriée pour
engager le renouvellement parc nucléaire
le paragraphe 10 indique que les
conditions d'application de cet article
doivent être précisés par un décret en
Conseil d'État très intéressant aussi
l'article 6 indique que chaque
fournisseur d'électricité donc tout
nouvel entrant doit disposer de
garanties quelles sont ses garanties les
capacités d'effacement de consommation
et de production d'électricité je dis
bien capacité d'effacement et de
capacité de production visant je cite à
assurer la sécurité d'approvisionnement
donc quand on vous dit la loi et ou la
loi l'homme n'a absolument pas
proposé que les nouveaux entrants
participent aux capacités de production
c'est faux suicide relire le texte de la
loi ce même article précise qu'un
fournisseur qui ne justifie pas qui
détient la garantie de capacité on court
dans un premier temps une sanction
pécuniaire
sanction pécuniaire entre guillemets
c'est dans le dans le texte de la loi et
dans un second temps le ministre chargé
de l'énergie peut je cite suspendre sans
délai l'autorisation d'exercice de
l'activité d'achat par vente enfin et
j'ai noté que personne n'en parle jamais
l'article 16 définit ce que peut-être je
cite un abus du droit d'accès régulé à
l'électricité nucléaire historique cet
article est essentiel il vise et le mot
figure précisément dans le texte le
détournement des principes de la reine
j'étais un peu long j'en suis navré mais
je voulais devant vous rétablir les
faits et à dire le vrai je me suis
demandé si tous les commentateurs et n'y
voyez pas d'offense certains députés qui
mettent en cause la loi nomme et qui lui
prête tous les mots avait ne serait-ce
que pris le temps de la lire
lorsque j'ai quitté le ministère les
décrécités en Conseil d'État étaient en
préparation et les avis requis demandés
les avis requis étaient demandés pour ce
qui concerne les obligations de capacité
je me souviens que début mai 2012 le
Conseil d'État nous avait déjà transmis
son avis
c'est décrets ont-ils été pris
personnellement je ne les ai pas trouvé
et j'ai cherché sur internet ce sont les
seuls moyens dont je dispose aujourd'hui
mais vous avez d'autres moyens
d'investigation que que les miens donc
vous pouvez vérifier par ailleurs comme
on l'a vu le gouvernement devait
remettre des rapports d'évaluation et
proposer des améliorations du dispositif
j'ai vu des rapports de l'Autorité de la
concurrence de la creux et de la Cour
des comptes mais je n'ai pas vu ceux du
gouvernement est-ce qu'ils existent si
oui que disait-il que préconisait-il
qu'elles adaptations proposaient-ils
enfin le dispositif doit prendre fin le
31 décembre 2025 c'est très bientôt 31
décembre 2025 quels sont les pistes
proposées pour remplacer la reine
le rappel de que je viens de vous faire
de certains articles de la loi montre
aussi clairement que la loi donné au
gouvernement la possibilité la
possibilité d'ajuster en permanence le
prix de la reine en tenant compte de
tous les éléments possibles le marché
l'évolution du coût d'exploitation les
investissements de maintenance et de
renouvellement du parc pourquoi est-ce
que cela n'a pas été fait ou ça a été
fait ponctuellement 2022 on augmentant
et le plafond et les prix mais pourquoi
le prix de la reine est-il toujours en
2023 celui de 2011 ou de 2012 alors ce
qui alors qu'il devait être revu chaque
année les nouveaux entrants devaient je
vous l'ai dit contribuer à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et aux capacités de
production est-ce qu'ils l'ont fait et
est-ce que ceux qui ne l'auraient pas
fait est-ce qu'ils ont été contraints
comme la loi le demander et s'ils n'ont
pas été contraints et si non pas enfin
s'ils ont été contraints et qu'ils n'ont
pas respecté les obligations ont-ils été
comme la loi le demander mise en demeure
enfin puisque tout le monde a affirmé
que dans leur dernière période la reine
aurait fortement déstabilisé le marché
de l'électricité au détriment de DF si
c'est le cas et pourquoi pas si c'est le
cas les ministres chargés de l'énergie
et de l'économie avait et ont toujours
le droit de suspendre le dispositif la
loi de l'homme prévoit je vous l'ai dit
cette suspension en cas de circonstances
exceptionnelle affectant les centrales
c'est dans la loi donc l'arrêt du d'une
partie du parc du fait du phénomène du
phénomène dit de corrosion sous
contrainte le justifier me semble-t-il
et le justifie peut-être encore
allègrement voilà quelques questions
qu'à mon avis vous pourriez
utilement je
n'entre pas mes prérogatives en disant
cela aborder avec les ministres de
l'énergie qui m'ont succédé je termine
d'un mot ma conviction par l'eau ça a
été fait alors je dirais avec
ah d'accord
je lirai avec gourmandise le
compte-rendu
d'un mot pour finir ma conviction
personnelle et que la reine n'est qu'un
prétexte oui l'Union européenne ne pense
pas toujours comme nous oui il existe
c'est pas la peine de
le nier un tropisme que j'appellerai
libéral orthodoxe en matière de
concurrence à Bruxelles qui doit être
parfois corrigée parfois combattu et
c'est ce que nous faisons régulièrement
mais mettre sur le dos de Bruxelles nos
propres carences et nos propres erreurs
de politique énergétique non seulement
est trop facile mais à mon avis est vain
parce que ça n'est pas comme ça qu'on
pourra regarder lucidement la situation
de notre pays et répondre au défi du
temps qui vient
j'espère avoir répondu à votre
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
cette ces éléments très clairs qui
j'allais dire qui mettent les points sur
les i mais qui remettent les barres sur
le h
une question quand même parce que il y a
quelque chose qui sous le contrôle de
mes collègues a été très que de manière
très récurrente et très forte critiquée
en ce qui concerne la reine dans son
principal pas dans son actualisation et
de la façon dont c'est c'est son
asymétrie c'est l'idée que finalement ce
soit une option pour les fournisseurs
alternatifs quels sont les raisons qui
ont présidé à ce choix que ce soit une
option asymétrique et pas un quota qui
finalement devrait être acheté
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure personne
n'a envie de mourir pour le pour la
reine et c'est pas le plus beau des
édifices que qui était qui était
construit c'est un texte de compromis
nous avions souscrit à l'ouverture à la
concurrence
et nous avions accepté d'ouvrir notre
marché comment à la fois protéger on
pouvait pas le dire de cette façon là le
monopole de DF sur la production
nucléaire tout en satisfaisant les
obligations auxquelles nous avions
souscrites cette idée de dire puisqu'il
y a ce qu'on appelait moi je détestais
le mot mais c'est celui qui était
utilisé à l'époque une rente du
nucléaire autrement dit que les non
centrales avaient été déjà
financièrement amorti et que donc on
nous étions dans le coût marginal
il faut offrir la possibilité
aux nouveaux entrants aux alternatives
comme on disait la possibilité de
construire mais construire encore une
fois
non seulement en achetant mais en
achetant pour bâtir un outil industriel
je pardon de paraître un peu
obsessionnel devant vous ce matin mais
il y avait l'obligation d'offrir des
capacités de production et d'effacement
et c'est donc l'idée du coup de pouce
entre guillemets qui devait être donné à
un certain nombre de nouveaux
producteurs par ailleurs nous estimons
qu'on fixant à 42 euros le mégawattheure
nous avions je le dis pudiquement bien
traité EDF
et que encore une fois la force de notre
part que nucléaire allait permettre à
EDF d'aller elle l'a fait sur les
marchés à l'export aucun d'entre nous
n'aurait accepté à l'époque un
dispositif si nous avions eu le
sentiment que nous allions fragiliser
EDF vous parliez tout à l'heure monsieur
le Président de contexte j'allais dire
que la protection d'EDF faisait partie
des fondamentaux du gouvernement auquel
j'appartenais donc très franchement à la
question ne se posait pas et d'ailleurs
je parle sous votre contrôle et et
et le fruit des auditions auxquelles
vous avez procédé finalement la reine ne
pose vraiment problème que depuis les
années 2018 depuis 2019 puisqu'on ayant
fixé un plafond de mémoire sans terrasse
là aussi je crois qu'il n'a été que
rarement atteint ce plafond autrement
dit à ce prix là les alternatives ont
longtemps
considérés que finalement il n'en
n'avait pas besoin c'est lorsque les
prix de ont augmenté du fait notamment
de la décision allemande là aussi pardon
de par être obsessionnel mais je pense
qu'elle a beaucoup pesé sur le sur le
marché puis ensuite
l'intervention militaire russe en
Ukraine que les conditions de marché ont
fondamentalement changé même si j'ai cru
comprendre qu'on revient à une en ce
moment à une période un peu moins tendue
donc pour répondre à votre quai question
c'est une un équilibre qui a été
recherché
à l'époque par Jean-Louis Borloo mais
quand je vous avais compris que quand je
dis par Jean-Louis Borloo ça n'est pas
une façon de me dédouaner puisque je
vous ai dit que j'assumais totalement ce
que nous avons fait
une dernière question sur l'Europe parce
que vous l'avez dit en creux mais c'est
pour être sûr de vous avoir bien compris
parce que vous avez parlé d'EDF mais
plus généralement vous avez dit que le
gouvernement de l'époque a accepté en
faisant des compromis et en faisant le
maximum vous l'avez cité sur la reine et
sur le la loi Nome en prévoyant les
possibilités de de comprendre l'ensemble
des aspects qui étaient importants pour
la filière mais ce que vous soulignez
c'est que hors crise et période
exceptionnelle l'ouverture à la
concurrence la libéralisation et donc la
possibilité d'avoir des échanges
interconnectés au niveau européen a
plutôt bénéficié à la filière et
industriellement et économiquement y
compris du point de vue du dispatching
de l'énergie sur le territoire européen
vous est apparu une bonne chose sans je
cherche pas à faire du rétrospectif et à
nier la partie crise évidemment mais
dans le principe et dans la décennie qui
a suivi
d'un point de vue idéologique sont
utilisés de trop gros mots ça peut être
discuter l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir des
monopoles dans un certain nombre de
mènes moi et quelque chose qui ne me
choquait pas si on regarde à posteriori
la séparation des activités production
distribution
[Musique]
réseau a plutôt bien fonctionné en
définitive en tout cas bien mieux que
des craintes parfois légitimes que l'on
que l'on pouvait que l'on pouvait avoir
ensuite même si nous ne l'avons pas
souhaité au départ et que la France l'a
accepté au prix de compromis lié à cette
fameuse construction européenne qui est
une négociation permanente la
construction européenne vous acceptez
vous demander un certain nombre de
choses à vos partenaires et vous
acceptez en contrepartie un certain
nombre de de
si je peux me permettre de rebondir
dans votre description du de la loi
nomme
vous précisez que vous envisagiez qu'un
éventuel détournement des principes de
l'arène
permettent également de mettre fin à la
reine lorsque nous avons auditionné le
directeur de l'énergie de l'époque il
nous a notamment dit nous n'imaginions
pas à l'époque une circonstance de
marché qui conduisent à ce que
le prix de la reine soit à ce point
inférieur au prix de marché
et nous n'imaginons pas non plus une
circonstance dans lesquelles les gens
renoncent à acheter de la reine parce
que sur les marchés il y avait des prix
plus intéressants enfin des variabilité
aussi aussi massive du prix de des prix
de marché du coup la question que je me
pose c'est quels sont ces détournements
de principe
détournement des principes de la reine
que vous imaginiez de telle sorte à
inscrire dans la loi qu'il puisse mettre
fin à l'existence du mécanisme
si vous permettez il y a deux choses
distinctes dans votre dans votre
question est-ce qu'à l'époque les
initiateurs et les et les promoteurs de
la loi dont je n'étais pas puisque moi
j'ai pas je n'ai pas participé au
travaux préparatoires à la loi l'homme
mais
je devine suffisamment qu'effectivement
lorsqu'il bâtit ce dispositif tout le
monde a plutôt l'impression que les prix
ont tendance ne vont cesser d'augmenter
et peu j'imagine prévoit que qu'à
certains moments dans un certain nombre
de circonstances il va y avoir la chute
qu'on a connu à un certain moment sur le
sur le marché ça c'est sans doute vrai
et j'imagine que le directeur général
qui vous a dit ça
l'a dit de bonne foi après il y a autre
chose que vise l'article 16 de la loi
que je citais le détournement là très
clairement si ça va être envisagé
puisque moi quand je prends connaissance
j'arrive au ministère je sais que
quelques jours après je vais devoir
aller en séance de nuit pour défendre le
texte de la loi norme dans ces cas-là
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous enfermez
dans votre bureau avec le cabinet que
vous venez de nommer et les directeurs
d'administration centrale et d'abord
vous essayez de vérifier que vous
comprenez vous-même très bien ce que
vous allez de défendre au Parlement et
donc quand je pose la question de cet
article 16 qui d'ailleurs n'est pas
débattu en seconde séance à l'Assemblée
puisque le
on débat d'un certain nombre de points
mais on reprend le texte du Sénat qui
est qui était qui était revenu le
détournement ça veut dire très
clairement c'est un dispositif
antispeculateur
ça veut dire que si quelqu'un
prétend entrer sur le marché pour ne
faire que du trading et ne jamais
apporter de capacité de production ou
d'effacement la loi donne au ministre de
l'énergie conjointement avec le ministre
de l'économie dans une architecture
différente puisque moi j'étais placé
auprès du ministre de de l'économie leur
donne à tous les deux le pouvoir
d'écarter celui qui ne respecterait pas
l'esprit de la loi et les fondamentaux
de la reine
une dernière question justement sur les
énergies renouvelables
à partir de
2007-2008
l'augmentation d'installation de
capacité de production par des sources
renouvelables comment ça se stagner en
France et c'est le début du décrochage
entre les objectifs
qui ont été fixés à l'horizon 2020
notamment et puis le la capacité
atteindre quand vous arrivez aux
responsabilités qu'elle analyse on vous
fait des difficultés d'installer des
énergies renouvelables et est-ce que
vous prenez des mesures pour vous avez
parlé dont on a parlé des appels
d'offres pour l'éolien offshore
peut-être un peu en avoir un peu plus de
détails sur la partie photovoltaïque et
éolien terrestre dont vous décrivez le
retard français qui semble inéluctable
mais à la fois sur la capacité à
construire une filière industrielle et
puis sur la capacité à installer des
énergies renouvelables sur notre sol
quelle est la situation de départ quand
vous arrivez et comment est-ce que vous
essayez de la faire évoluer
deux choses d'abord si nous étions dans
un débat partisan ce qui n'est pas le
cas je contesterai votre préambule non
non je ne le fais que modérément parce
que ça n'a pas c'est pas d'un grand
enjeu pour moi aujourd'hui et pour vous
sans doute non plus mais en
2012 je me souviens très bien de nos
argumentaires de l'époque la France a
atteint les objectifs qu'elle s'était
fixée j'ai des j'ai des notes sur le
sujet que que et même on s'empargue pour
vous dire des choses franchement on les
a même atteint plus plus vite que que
prévu mais honnêtement pour moi ce n'est
que
cannecdotique d'autant que
comment dire je n'en suis pas le premier
responsable au bon sens du terme
c'est-à-dire que s'il y a des lauriers à
prendre
ma contribution
limitée
dans quel cadre ça se ça se fait il est
très simple moi je suis un bon soldat le
président de la République a pris des
engagements post-grenel nous devons avec
Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet les mettre en
oeuvre simplement nous le faisons et moi
à Bercy c'est ma très grande
préoccupation en essayant de me demander
en permanence comment on va faire pour
que les les
engagements auxquels nous avons souscrit
ne se retourne pas contre nous pour le
ce qui concerne nos filières
industrielles alors pour l'éolien
offshore ça a été relativement plus
facile ça a coûté beaucoup d'argent en
rapport qualité-prix on
sincèrement on pourrait discuter mais si
on est
bienveillant on va dire que c'était le
prix à payer pour lancer une filière il
y avait encore de l'espace pour le faire
et qu'est-ce qu'on avait fait
on avait mis dans le cahier des charges
des textes européens ne nous le
permettait l'idée que était valorisée la
production à proximité des lieux objets
de l'appel d'offre et donc évidemment si
vous produisez à 50 ou 100 km vous étiez
largement
avantagés par rapport au fait que vous
le fassiez à 1000 ou 8000 km voilà pour
ce qui concerne les autres énergies
renouvelables le solaire l'éolien etc
très franchement c'était très compliqué
parce que notre industrie était
balbichon EDF avait investir acheté si
je me souviens bien
une société de renouvelable
etc etc mais très franchement nous
étions faibles sur le sujet et moi ma
préoccupation paradoxalement en
permanence c'était de me dire oh là là
mais ça va ça va coûter très cher et
pour quel résultat pour l'industrie
française et d'ailleurs c'est sur cette
base que nous avions pris un moratoire
qui a été arbitré parce que
à l'intérieur du du gouvernement les
avis n'étaient pas les mêmes et donc ça
a été arbitré par le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre nous
avons été obligés de mettre un moment un
moratoire sur le sur le solaire parce
que tout simplement on voyait que la
ligne de pente était catastrophique
financièrement et catastrophique
sur le plan de l'outil industriel alors
les choses ont un peu évolué depuis que
le soleil
s'est développé son prix de son prix de
revient à diminuer on n'est plus
aujourd'hui exactement dans la même
situation en revanche d'un point de vue
strictement industriel je ne suis pas
sûr qu'on est fait des progrès tels que
on puisse consolider le
l'industrie française je voulais dit
tout à l'heure
quand on fait du solaire par exemple pas
seulement du solaire
c'est du solaire chinois pour plus de
50% je crois près de 60%. et j'en
profite pour vous dire par accident mais
si vous ne m'avez pas posé la question
que pour l'avenir il y a un autre sujet
qui m'inquiète c'est le véhicule
électrique propre nous avons pris si
j'ai bien compris la décision de passer
au véhicules électriques en 2035 et donc
d'interdire les automobiles à moteur
thermique
la vente neuve très bien la vente
parfait moi je souscris à l'objectif
quand j'étais à Bercy j'ai aussi essayé
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
d'apporter ma contribution à cet
objectif qui me qui me paraît très
simple
mais attention
en 2035 c'est ça va aller très vite
est-ce que est-ce que nos producteurs
automobiles français seront capables de
tenir cet objectif ou est-ce qu'une
nouvelle fois on va acheter que ou
quasiment que des véhicules électriques
asiatiques et notamment chinois
j'en ai profité parce que c'est une
chose d'inquiétude pour moi sincèrement
on veut tous le véhicule propre ça peut
être le
l'avion un jour c'est un des grands
sujets source d'émissions de CO2 etc
mais il faut concilier en permanence la
préoccupation
environnemental et la préoccupation
industrielle sinon on se déshabille
je vous remercie j'en ai fini simplement
pour la complétude du débat je mes
chiffres de tout à l'heure viennent du
service statistique du ministère de la
transition écologique des chiffres de
2017 portant sur la période de 2000 à
2017 pour pour la bonne conciliation
en tout cas monsieur ministre merci
Monsieur ministre monsieur Dubois
oui je voudrais revenir sur donc vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure sur les
scénaris de RTE et vous avez notamment
dit que certains vous paraissaient
farfelus donc l'idée c'est que vous
précisiez lesquels et donc pour pouvoir
se projeter
dans l'avenir qu'est-ce qui vous
paraîtrait le scénario le plus idéal en
mix pour pouvoir faire face justement
vous l'avez évoqué à tous ces choix
politiques du tout électrique
et notamment avec les économies qui
peut-être seront en matière d'économie
d'énergie seront peut-être pas au
rendez-vous comme on peut nous
l'annoncer donc dans les pour ceux qui
les prennent en matière politique je
vous remercie
merci
sur la première partie de votre question
peut-être que je devrais être plus
modeste que je n'ai été tout à l'heure
normalement je ne devrais rendre compte
et vous dire devant vous que
auquel tu as quoi j'ai participé ou de
dont je suis responsable je me suis
permis ensuite des commentaires sur une
période que je n'ai pas eu à connaître
et que je ne connais pas simplement
comme tout citoyen j'ai été intéressé
par le sujet donc quand vous avez
travaillé dans un domaine comme celui-là
qui en plus un domaine passionnant et
majeur vous suivez dans les dans les
journaux ce que ce qu'on était les
décisions prises ou les ou les débats et
que donc quand j'ai vu que RTE j'ai cité
RTE mais je crois que l'ADEME a fait la
même chose et que d'autres ont fait
ont évoqué
un scénario 100% renouvelable et donc à
l'époque je me souvenais plus mais j'ai
souri quand j'ai vu toutes les
conditions qu'ils mettaient à la
réalisation de de ce scénario autrement
dit affichage du scénario et en même
temps en creux dire qu'il était
totalement impossible à réaliser pour
pour la France je me suis dit très
franchement que c'est pas une bonne
façon de faire de la pédagogie parce que
quiconque ne lit que les titres je veux
dire bah finalement un scénario 100%
renouvelable en France c'est possible or
non sauf à une régression totale qu'il
faut
dire expliciter et justifier
voilà alors après de façon fondamentale
je crois que il n'y a pas de en tout cas
c'est la conclusion que moi j'ai tiré
personnellement des années que j'ai
passé dans dans ce ministère
peut-être aussi la convention que
j'avais en arrivant mais elle est
largement renforcée il n'y a pas de bon
mix énergétique
générale qu'on pourrait appeler au
niveau mondial
chaque pays doit définir son mix
énergétique en fonction de ses
caractéristiques propres et de ses
atouts moi je vis et je travaille
maintenant dans un pays qui est le pays
dans lequel je suis né qui est le qui
est le Maroc
je vois le plan
on dirait en France le plan vert le plan
renouvelable que le Maroc développe et
qui est très ambitieux très puissant
mais je dirais de mon point de vue le
Maroc a entièrement raison il n'a pas
d'énergie fossile il est doté par la
nature d'un soleil plus qu'abondant et
généreux du vent dans beaucoup de
régions et il est en train de de créer
une spécificité en plus
constitué à 15 km de l'Espagne par des
trois de Gibraltar il pourrait être un
fournisseur d'électricité dites verte
pour l'Union européenne il a raison de
développer cette cette stratégie donc
mais on est en France un grand pays
industriel qui l'est encore et qui
prétend le rester qui a un certain
nombre de grandes agglomérations qui n'a
pas autant de de soleil que que des pays
que je que je deviens de citer c'est ça
aussi l'aberration européenne il y a le
plus de panneaux solaires dans le nord
de l'Europe il faut pas être un très
grand expert pour comprendre que un
petit problème fondamental dans notre
conception donc quand vous êtes un grand
pays la question fondamentale selon moi
si celle du socle de vous pouvez il faut
avoir un socle de l'ordre de moi je dis
de 70% vous pouvez dire 65 75 peu
importe un socle commandable pilotable
stable sur lesquels vous ne dépendez
absolument pas de la météo
du vent du soleil du grand froid etc ce
stock stable en France de quoi peut-il
être constitué je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure de l'hydroélectricité mais
malheureusement il y a une limite on
peut peut-être marginalement améliorer
un petit peu certains parlent des
steppes d'autres de la microélectricité
oui il y a peut-être une petite marge
d'amélioration de notre hydroélectricité
soit mais pour le reste derrière pour un
pays comme la France c'est du nucléaire
ou du gaz ou du charbon
c'est ça le choc alors moi je préfère
largement le nucléaire pour les raisons
toutes les raisons que j'ai indiquées
devant cette commission ensuite il y a
de la pointe je dis de la pointe et pas
de la pointe parce que le la pointe
quand on dit c'est on va faire du
nucléaire et du renouvelable pour la
pointe mais ça tient pas la route je
vous citais de tout à l'heure l'exemple
de février 2012 quand on a atteint le
pic de consommation quand il y a un
anticyclone qui te fait nuit qu'à 19h
tout le monde allume sa télé sa maison
son son four etc parce que concrètement
c'est comme ça que ça se passe il y a
pas une éolienne qui tourne qui fait
nuit qui a pas de soleil et qu'on a pas
de stockage massif d'électricité
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
voilà comment dire
on peut avoir des des débats éthérés sur
un certain nombre de questions et
ensuite il y a une donnée fondamentale
alors ça ne
cherche pas à atténuer ce que je viens
de dire je la fais avec force ça
n'empêche pas que vous avez le droit de
chercher à économiser des énergies
utiliser des techniques dites
d'effacement etc etc oui Linky
ce compteur dit intelligent les Smart
Grids etc qui ont été malheureusement
critiqués je n'ai jamais exactement
compris pourquoi mais mais peu importe
peuvent y contribuer mais le socle si
vous voulez être un grand pays
avancé un grand pays industriel il est
majeur et pour moi je ne je n'ai jamais
compris pourquoi nous mettions en cause
notre choc
je vais plus loin et je vous dis un mot
qui est personnel
parfois on m'a un peu reproché on m'a
dit tu parais réticent dans la mise en
œuvre
des politiques dit d'énergie
renouvelable bon j'étais pas réticent je
dis tout à l'heure j'ai appliqué ce que
le président de la République avait fait
mais c'est vrai que dans mon fort
intérieur je me suis posé un certain
nombre de questions je me suis toujours
demandé pourquoi alors que nous avions
cet atout fondamental pourquoi nous
n'avons pas attendu d'abord pourquoi on
a souscrit à des engagements et pour
dire aux rapporteur je ne sais pas si
c'est le gouvernement auquel j'ai
appartenu où les suivants donc vous
voyez je cherche pas à raconter des
histoires sur le sujet qui a souscrit à
l'idée que on pouvait avoir des amendes
importantes si nous ne respections pas
nos objectifs
en matière de renouvelable pour moi
c'est un non sens si l'Europe doit se
préoccuper de deux choses
ce sont de nos émissions de CO2 et là il
y aurait matière à sanctionner et par
ailleurs de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement ce qui était au
départ je le rappelle la préoccupation
en 57 de la création de râteaux ça oui
ça devrait être sous le la comment dire
la vigilance permanente de l'Union
européenne de sa commission etc et de
dire on va sanctionner ce qui émettent
trop de CO2 je trouve que ça serait
totalement légitime mais de le faire par
rapport à un pourcentage qui fait que la
France qui est plutôt moins émettrice
que d'autres pays en Europe et dans le
monde pourrait être sanctionné parce
qu'elle
n'atteint pas tel objectif de
renouvelable personnellement je n'ai
plus de mandat je n'inspire plus à part
en avoir donc je suis très tranquille
pour le dire je trouve ça absolument
absurde des grotesque mais je reviens
d'un mot à ce que je vous disais moi
l'impression que j'avais il y a 10 ans
c'est que comme lorsqu'on était
tellement fort on avait un tel atout
avec le nucléaire nous aurions pu avoir
intérêt à attendre un peu avant de nous
précipiter attendre que le prix marginal
du soleil de l'éolien etc diminue
profiter de ce laps de temps pour
construire des filières industrielles
solides lorsque vous n'êtes pas en
avance en matière industrielle comme
quand on disait moi quand j'étais au
numérique tout le monde me disait
comment on va faire pour construire le
ou pour imaginer le prochain le nouveau
Google bah non il y a assez peu de
chance avec l'effet de cliquer de
barrière que vous aviez demain à nouveau
Google la place prise par Google
est-elle vous pouvez avoir d'autres
moteurs de recherche mais vous n'allez
pas remplacer Google ce qui est
intéressant c'est de d'avoir une une
vision
disruptive entre guillemets de dire
puisque j'ai loupé le départ qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour le rattraper par
un saut technologique et personnellement
et ce serait encore le cas aujourd'hui
je dirais pour au lieu de courir après
des technologies qui existent des déjà
et sur lesquels un certain nombre de
pays comme la Chine par exemple ont mis
des moyens absolument colossaux que nous
ne serons pas capables et nous n'en
n'avons pas les finances pour les mettre
en oeuvre essayons de nous dire quels
sont dans ces matières renouvelables
je stockage massif de l'électricité
c'est l'enjeu majeur mais si on parle
que du renouvelable quels sont les
technologies de dans cinq ans ou dans 10
ans et avons-nous une chance de nous
placer sur le sujet plutôt que de courir
après un prix qui me paraît faramineux
merci beaucoup madame Leernes
oui merci j'ai 5 sujets aux thématiques
je voudrais commencer par les énergies
renouvelables puisque vous avez je vous
cite sur cette audition exprimer à
l'instant les arguments que nous avons
les engagements que nous avions souscrit
ne se veillez à ce qu'il ne se retourne
pas contre nous et vous venez aussi
d'évoquer votre scepticisme face à la
filière des énergies renouvelables en
France
vous dites sur les énergies
renouvelables je vous cite encore un sur
cette audition
nous favorisons l'importation chinoise
tout le monde savait que la conso
électrique allait augmenter vous dites
sur le scénario élaboré 100% énergies
renouvelable de RTE
ça allait créer tellement de dégâts
personne de sérieux ne pouvait
sérieusement le soutenir
son président n'en croit pas un mot
c'est une tendance dangereuse pour votre
pays je le dis juste que vous avez dit
lors de
lors de votre audition
et puis vous avez rappelé que pour vous
il y a pour la sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique en
France et ça souveraineté que le gaz le
nucléaire et le charbon
on comprend peut-être mieux pourquoi il
n'y a pas eu de d'émergence de réels
filières des énergies renouvelables en
France et que le gouvernement des
gouvernements successifs il y en a
certains qui ont essayé de se batailler
y compris à l'Union européenne face au
dumping chinois pour justement faire
décroître notre dépendance
énergétique par rapport à ça ce qui
m'étonne au delà vous pouvez afficher
votre scepticisme et dire que le
nucléaire est va sauver le climat et que
l'Union européenne devrait
se concentrer sur la réduction des CO2
et faire en parallèle dans cette même
omission l'apologie de Total qui est un
contributeur net au réchauffement
climatique ce qui m'étonne c'est le
manque de parallèle sur puisque l'objet
de notre commission c'est de la
souveraineté l'indépendance énergétique
des autres filières énergétiques puisque
au début vous avez relaté qu'en tant que
ministre l'industrie vous êtes allé dans
divers pays étrangers nous sommes
dépendants puisque nous avons pas
suffisamment agi sur notre dépendance
notamment aux énergies fossiles et que
nous n'avons pas de pétrole que nous
n'avons pas de gaz sur le sol français
et que donc
je ne vous ai pas entendu beaucoup
parler pour comment on réduit notre
dépendance par rapport à ça et faire
uniquement l'apologie d'une seule
filière par ailleurs sur la filière du
nucléaire il me semble et vous l'avez
évoqué dans d'autres dans votre audition
également que les projets sont aussi
avec d'autres prix pays nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur la filière du nucléaire
aussi largement dépendant des contrats
assez avec des Russes avec rosatum vous
avez évoqué des projets avec le Japon
sur des réacteurs et il y a eu et ça a
été ça ne a pas dû passer inaperçue
auprès de vous des problématiques en
tout cas entre Areva et EDF quant à la
collaboration ou la suspicion d'Arena de
vendre un certain nombre de savoir-faire
à la Chine sur les réacteurs nucléaires
et donc ma question sur ce volet là est
assez simple est-ce que
vraiment si vous mettez bout à bout les
choses que vous avez dites vous-même
dans cette audition on est sincèrement
plus indépendant des forces étrangères
avec sans les énergies renouvelables
parce que c'est que à eux que vous
donnez ce mot alors qu'il me semble que
sur toutes les autres filières c'est
aussi avéré
vous motorisez une question qui est une
vérification madame et vous prie de
m'excuser parce que je ne vous
connaissais pas j'imagine que vous êtes
de sensibilité verte ou écologique c'est
ça
la réponse vous appartient
j'ai aucune problématique à vous
répondre mais souvent et dans les
réponses que vous avez faites
considérant et nommant caractérisant y
compris des présidents de RCE ou
d'autres qui ont posé des scénarios 100%
énergies renouvelables de pas sérieux de
pas crédible j'imagine que votre
question m'a j'assume pleinement mes
convictions et mon appartenance à Europe
Écologie Les Verts mais
si ça fait partie de votre processus de
réponse pour décrédibiliser la personne
qui vous pose des questions sérieuses
fondées
j'aimerais bien vous avez cinq
thématiques de questions j'ai aucune
difficulté à ce que vous les posiez
après la réponse à chaque fois
j'aimerais que ce ne soit pas un débat
mais bien des questions si dans les
réponses monsieur le ministre venait à
avoir des propos qui vous dérangent
quand à votre engagement politique ou à
la crédibilité de vos questions je pense
que vous serez en mesure d'y répondre
mais a priori il n'y a pas de raison de
penser cela Monsieur le Ministre bon
d'abord si ma question vous paraissait
au front centre je m'en excuse elle
était
et elle se voulait neutre je cherchait
pas absolument à vous disqualifier je il
me semblait que vous exprimiez fortement
une sensibilité je voulais vérifier mais
j'aurais pu m'en abstenir et si ça vous
a froissé je m'en excuse je me demande
de m'en excuser
excuse pour excuse la la mise bout à
bout comme vous dites de tout ce que
j'ai dit et que j'ai effectivement dit
me paraît un montage un peu particulier
parce que je n'ai absolument pas dit que
je me désintéressais
des énergies renouvelables j'ai dit très
exactement le contraire je crois même
avoir utilisé l'expression que dans mes
fonctions j'ai été un bon soldat et que
j'ai scrupuleusement mis en œuvre les
exigences du président de la République
et du Premier ministre qui ont été des
respecter les engagements pris par le
Grenelle de l'environnement je l'ai fait
scrupuleusement et je conteste et
maublement courtoisement la pression du
rapporteur tout à l'heure et je lui
fournirai je vous
fournirez madame des éléments qui
montrent qu'en 2012 nous avions respecté
les engagements que nous en ayons pris
en matière d'énergie renouvelable je
n'ai pas fait l'apologie de Total j'ai
dit que c'était un atout pour la France
d'avoir pour sa sécurité
d'approvisionnement un certain nombre de
grands énergéticiens qui assurent notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement total en
matière de pétrole et gaz GDF Suez
devenu engie en matière de gaz et ça je
le maintiens
oui bon c'est c'est vrai vous avez
raison je me suis permis une incidence
sur l'actualité dont j'aurais pu me
passer mais mais je vais vous en faire
une autre quand je vois que sur les
débats sur le retraite la seule cible
principale qu'on a c'est Bernard Arnault
et LVMH qui est un formidable outil
industriel pour la France et qui est un
de nos principaux atout majeurs je ne
comprends pas je suis d'accord je suis
hors cadre énergie et pétrole donc je
reviens à ce cadre pour y revenir très
exactement ce que j'ai dit à votre
collègue député c'est que à titre
personnel vous pouvez à la fois mener
une action je l'ai fait rigoureusement
avec Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet et nous
l'avons fait je me suis permis de faire
part d'un sentiment personnel pas de mon
action mon sentiment personnel qui était
que de se précipiter pour atteindre des
objectifs alors même que nous n'avions
pas de filière industrielle suffisamment
constitué me paraissait dommage que
c'est toujours le cas aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes pas en pointe en matière
d'énergie éolienne nous ne sommes pas en
pointe dans la production de panneaux
photovoltaïques etc et que ma suggestion
d'un point de vue industriel c'est de
dire prépare au lieu d'importer
lourdement des des outils que nous ne
fabriquons pas préparant l'avenir
c'était une parenthèse de conviction
personnelle dans mon action
ministérielle j'ai respecté
scrupuleusement ce qui nous a été
demandé je réponds à votre question oui
il se trouve que mon mandat a été marqué
par un certain nombre de pour tout vous
dire quand je suis arrivé au ministère
de
l'Industrie énergie et du numérique je
ne m'attendais pas sur l'énergie à ce
que le nucléaire prenne tant de place
c'est pas de ma faute si il y a eu un
accident à Fukushima que certains en ont
tiré des conclusions et que ces
conclusions et ses conséquences ont
profondément marqué la politique
française et la politique européenne il
a fallu faire avec j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure parce que c'était la question du
rapporteur de ce que nous avions fait en
matière de pétrole gaz et métaux
spéciaux mais je pouvais vous raconter
comment je suis allé au Canada
regardez ce que faisons les ce que
faisaient les Canadiens qui sont très
bien dotés en matière d'Hydro et
électricité ou de d'un certain nombre de
réunions de travail consacrés à la
filière industrielle ce sont aussi les
les sujets à la fois de votre commission
et d'actualité qui pèsent sur des
réponses mais ça ne veut pas dire que le
spectre de ce sur quoi on travaille est
limité à ce qu'on est en train de
d'évoquer
voilà
juste du coup vous m'avez pas répondu à
ma question c'est à dire que pour les
énergies renouvelables vous disais nous
favorisons l'importation chinoise vous
venez d'expliquer pourquoi la France n'a
pas mis les moyens pour créer des
filières qui étaient balbutiantes sur
les énergies renouvelables et pour
autant sur le pétrole sur le gaz sur le
nucléaire je viens de vous citer les
projets et les relations de la France et
des grandes entreprises françaises du
nucléaire avec les pays étrangers et
donc vous refusez du coup de répondre à
cette question pour qualifier par
rapport à la l'indépendance énergétique
française sur ces sujets là dans le sens
y compris que il y a une part sur
l'indépendance la technologie et après
il y a la matière il y a les deux sujets
il y a la technologie sur le nucléaire
c'est des centrales le combustible le
anium et sur les énergies renouvelables
vous avez la technologie pour capter des
choses des matières à partir duquel on
fabrique de l'énergie qui est disponible
partout et que
nous sommes donc pas dépendants
d'importation de l'étranger donc par
rapport à l'objet de notre commission
d'enquête c'est simplement là-dessus
aussi que poser ma question
madame la députée avec tout le respect
que je vous dois je le refuse pas à
votre de répondre à votre question je
refuse de répondre à la façon dont vous
voulez orienter ma réponse ou dont vous
dont vous résumez mes propos ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose je
ne vous ai pas dit une seule seconde je
vais redire pour la quatrième fois
l'inverse que nous n'avons pas cherché à
développer les filières industrielles en
matière d'énergie renouvelable nous
l'avons fait autant que nous le pouvions
en lançant des appels d'offres qui
respectaient les textes de la
concurrence européenne et de
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce mais
qui en même temps essayait chaque fois
appelons un chat un chat de favoriser
l'industrie française j'ai fait
simplement devant vous un constat auquel
je vous suggère de réfléchir c'est qu'il
y a un certain nombre de domaines dans
lesquels nous et nous avons lancé tous
les appels d'offres tous les appels à
projets avec Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet
qui était inclus dans les obligations et
les engagements post-grenelle de
l'environnement tous pas un seul n'a
manqué à la pelle je vous ai simplement
dit que les responsables politiques que
vous êtes aujourd'hui peuvent réfléchir
au fait que nous n'avons toujours pas
malgré les efforts que nous avons fait
vous savez vous ne décrétez pas en
quelques mois la naissance d'une d'une
filière
éolienne ou
photovoltaïques en France vous pouvez
encourager il y a eu des fonds pour ça
dans le cadre du grand emprunt exemple
très concret je n'ai pas les chiffres là
sous les yeux mais vous pourrez les
retrouver vous verrez ce qu'on a appelé
le grand emprunt après la crise de 2008
a consacré pour essayer d'aider et
stimuler les énergies les filières évite
d'énergie renouvelable mais ne confondez
pas une action qui a été celle que je
viens de vous dire une analyse
personnelle et une réflexion que je vous
soumets sur ce qu'a été notre
notre action par ailleurs vous avez
évoqué l'uranium sur l'uranium la France
sont Areva à cet efforté de diversifier
autant que possible ces sources
d'approvisionnement c'est passé par
l'Australie c'est passé par le Canada et
même s'il subsiste une des importations
qui peuvent être soumises à terme à des
tensions le Kazakhstan le Niger et un
certain nombre d'autres mais c'est
pourquoi je dis et je redis
qu'il me semble que ce que nous devrions
faire c'est lancer des démonstrateurs et
à terme des réacteur
quatrième génération qui nous
permettront de d'utiliser le l'uranium
appauvri dont nous disposons abondamment
sur notre sol le plutonium dont nous
disposons
abondamment et qui permettra d'ailleurs
au passage
d'atténuer le débat sur l'enfouissement
des déchets ou la radioactivité de de
long terme des déchets puisque à ce
moment-là on réduirait d'abord la
quantité de
très bien mais comme disait Georges
Marchais parfois ça peut être aussi
l'objet de ma réponse parce que vous me
vous me vous me demandez comment on peut
aller vers du vous me demandez comment
on peut aller vers durable et
vous avez citez vous-même l’uranium
comme une source de dépendance donc
quand je vous réponds qu'on peut sortir
de cette dépendance à l'uranium naturel
par les atouts dont nous disposons vous
me dites que c'est plus votre question
mais si c'était votre question c'est
vous qui avez abordé l'uranium donc je
ferai que j'y réponde
je ne souhaite pas rentrer dans un débat
et donc je vais poser mes questions sur
les différentes les différents sujets je
voulais juste noter que les différents
personnes que nous avons auditionnées
sur la possibilité de réaliser la
quatrième génération
Savary mais il y a pas mal de
scepticisme en tout cas il y a une
certitude c'est que si on y arrive ça ne
sera pas avant 20 30 40 plutôt horizons
2050 si jamais c'était possible et les
tentatives précédentes ont plutôt échoué
donc juste pour donc on a eu on a eu on
a eu des débats sur est-ce qu'on
qualifie de déchets etc
mais moi je voulais parler là sur la
moto
vous reprenez votre question
après j'ai peur d'oublier le cours de
votre question
quand vous dites ça n'a pas marché non
madame c'est fou ça a marché
insuffisamment avec des avec des
difficultés mais super Phénix a été
raccordé au réseau superfélix a
rencontré des difficultés incontestables
mais au moment où super Phénix est
arrêté et vous vous vérifierez auprès de
spécialistes ça sa production et de
l'ordre de 30% de ses capacités donc la
démonstration qu'on pouvait faire avec
Super Phénix c'était pas l'objet
principal de super Phénix mais la
démonstration est faite que même en
production on pouvait pourquoi Astrid
Astrid s'était à la fois pour
comment dire accroître le niveau de
sûreté puisque ça la question du sodium
peut poser des questions donc accroître
niveau de sûreté et permettent justement
d'utiliser les stocks de
plutonium d'aller vers ce que des
experts des experts appellent la
transmutation et diminuée le la part des
actinides je vais pas me faire plus
avant que je ne suis mais désactivé de
mineur c'est-à-dire ceux qui justement
peuvent durer quelques centaines ou
milliers de d'années certains disent
plus et de ramener de l'ordre de 300 ans
pour les déchets à très longue durée de
vie donc quand vous évoquez la
durabilité
et le
notre indépendance en matière d'uranium
je vous redis que selon moi nous pouvons
atteindre cet indépendance totale parce
qu'à ce moment-là nous en matière
d'électricité je parle bien
d'électricité nucléaire je ne parle pas
d'énergie au sens large mais
d'électricité nous pouvons atteindre
cette indépendance totale puisque nous
avons sur notre sol des stocks que nous
pouvons utiliser et qui nous rendrait
totalement indépendant oui vous avez
raison à 20 ans à 30 ans et alors et
alors
et à 20 ans et à 30 ans oui mais de
toute façon les lois de programmation
dont vous allez débattre dans dans
quelques semaines ou quelques mois elles
sont faites pour les 20 ou 30 ans qui
viennent
oui je m'étonne juste que du coup
l'arrête super Phénix ayant eu lieu
avant vos responsabilités que pendant
votre mandat si tel était votre croyance
sur la possibilité de se de cette
quatrième génération que vous ne l'ayez
pas mis en place souvent de mandat avec
la filière du nucléaire français tel
qu'elle était c'est là-dessus que je
voulais en venir
c'est sous votre mandat de ministre les
échecs de l'export de l'EPR à l'étranger
la décrédibilisation de la filière du
nucléaire qui a été causée notamment et
on a auditionné aussi bien madame le
Verjon que Monsieur Proglio donc du
conflit pas tant ils en ont fait état
également avec le recul est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
cette période et de ce qu'elle a
impliqué sur la filière nucléaire
enfin pour compléter ma question est-ce
que la guerre entre Areva et EDF
a influencé notamment la décision de ne
pas reconduire madame lovergeon à la
tête d'Areva ou est-ce qu'il y a eu
d'autres raisons comme le scandale du
Ramin le conflit donc arriva EDF et les
relations entre les deux dirigeants en
passant sur les soupçons de prise
illégale d'intérêt
d'abord d'un mot
sous moment-là plus exactement sous le
mandat du Président de la République et
les fonctions que qui m'avaient été
confiées pour la quatrième génération
nous avons lancé le programme Astrid et
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que si son
million lui avait été affectés dans le
cadre du grand emprunt donc cette
conviction que nous portions nous
l'avons inscrite dans les faits c'était
aussi une façon de récupérer toutes les
informations utiles des programmes
phœnix et super Phénix qui avait été
arrêtés et de permettre à la France de
se remettre sur un sujet qui intéresse
par ailleurs beaucoup de
pays dans le monde
sur la relation
EDF Areva je ne dirais pas guerre totale
ou guerre vous l'avez vous l'avez dit
les relations n'étaient pas bonnes j'ai
essayé d'expliquer tout à l'heure que il
y avait des problèmes de fond de métier
et puis évidemment des relations
personnelles qui ont pu contribuer à
abîmer cette relation que nous l'avons
tranché à la demande du Président de la
République c'est c'est l'objet de la
nomination d'EDF comme chef de fil ce
que vous appelez le scandale
UraMin je ne sais pas si c'est un
scandale ou pas c'est alluge à la
justice et à vous par vos enquêtes dans
dans décider très clairement ça ne ça
n'était pas il y avait des
questionsnements sur l'évaluation des
actifs miniers de d'Areva oui est-ce
qu'il n'y avait pas une surévaluation
mais il n'y avait rien qui ressemblait à
l'époque à un scandale pour ce qui
concerne à titre personnel d'abord je
rappelle qu'elle avait été reconduite
une fois elle a fait demanda successif
donc elle n'a pas été particulièrement
maltraitée mais
après discussion avec toutes les
personnes concernées et c'est ministres
présidents et leur ministre le président
de la République et le Premier ministre
à l'époque ont estimé qu'effectivement
ne pas reconduire à nos vergeon pouvait
être une source d'apaisement et c'est ça
a été le cas d'ailleurs puisque comme je
le dis tout à l'heure le successeur le
cours celle qui était le à l'époque le
numéro 2 d'Areva a très vite signé avec
EDF un accord technique et commercial
plus un des engagements de long terme
sur l'approvisionnement en l'uranium
donc je crois que ça objectivement
contribuer à l'apaisement et à ce moment
là nous avions dit très clairement je
crois que vous conseille de politique
nucléaire emporte trace que dans le
cadre de l'éventuelle appel d'offre
saoudien puisque l'Arabie Saoudite
s'apprêtait à lancer un grand appel
d'offres que EDF serait clairement le
chef de fil ce qui avait manqué à Abu
Dhabi pour répondre totalement à votre
question
il faudrait faire un audit approfondi
des réseaux pour lesquelles nous avons
manqué l'appel d'offres d'Abou Dhabi que
nous aurions dû en bonne logique
remportée et là oui pour le coup je
pense que la mauvaise relation les
mauvaises relations au sein de la
filière et notamment entre les effets
Areva ont contribué oui
une question sur Fukushima puisque c'est
vous l'avez dit vous-même un fait
marquant
vous étiez donc en charge
de la sûreté de la sécurité du nucléaire
et donc des populations lorsque
l'événement de Fukushima intervient sur
la fin de votre mandat en juin 2011
lorsqu’un journaliste M6 vous pose la
question sur la sécurité des
installations il veut vous montrer un
petit reportage vous arrachez votre
métro et vous quittez le plateau télé en
refusant de répondre la question est
pourquoi et est-ce que c'est bien
responsable en tant que ministre de
l'énergie au moment où une catastrophe
nucléaire de cette ampleur intervient et
qu'on est un des pays les plus
nucléarisés au monde est-ce que ce
n'était pas de votre responsabilité
justement de répondre de faire
transparence et de répondre aux
inquiétudes et aux questions qui
pouvaient y avoir
puisque il y avait peut-être besoin de
dire les choses ou est-ce que vous aviez
des choses que vous ne vouliez pas
révéler et que vous aviez à cacher en
matière de sûreté et de sécurité
nucléaire en tout cas cet événement
interroge
réponse neutre et sobre
d'abord je n'étais pas
et je ne dis pas pour me dédouaner mais
pour pour l'ajustesse des faits je
n'étais pas en charge de la sécurité et
de et de la sûreté d'abord la Sûreté
Nucléaire la loi dit qu'elle dépend
d'abord de l'opérateur EDF sous le
contrôle de l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire mais
les décrets d'application font que
Nathalie Kosciusko-Morizet et moi avons
effectivement la responsabilité je
dirais politique de ces questions que
nous partageons
je vais répondre surtout sur le fond
c'est plus important puis si vous voulez
je vous dirais un mot de l'altercation
entre guillemets M6 qui franchement me
paraît purement anecdotique et pas très
importantes mais sur le fond après faut
kushima je l'ai je l'ai dit très
clairement tout à l'heure trois jours
après je me rendais compte 3 jours après
le Président le premier ministre demande
à l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire nous
sommes les premiers en Europe à l'avoir
fait une revue systématique de toutes
les centrales pour tirer des conclusions
que l'on ne connaît pas encore puisqu'on
est en plein pendant encore pendant la
crise de Fukushima une semaine après je
vais au conseil
extraordinaire des ministres et je
plaide je l'ai dit tout à l'heure à la
fois pour que tous les Européens
détenant des centrales face le même
exercice que que le nôtre et que nous
adoptions des des
normes de sécurité les possible dites de
troisième génération
les opérateurs notamment EDF sont amenés
par l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire à
dire leur préconisations c'est sur ces
bases notamment que sont créés les
forces d'intervention rapide à proximité
de toutes les centrales pour apporter
des matériels de secours c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on décide qu'il y ait des
modèles des moteurs diesel de de secours
qui seront mis en hauteur en cas
d'inondation etc c'est à partir des
positions françaises que tout les pays
européens décident de faire le le même
exercice nous sommes allés très loin
sans engendrer des gros travaux je vous
avais dû noter la SN a rendu ces travaux
fin d'année 2011 début d'année
2012 EDF les a fait ça ça coûtait cher
et parfois ça le temps notamment on a
essayé de renforcer toutes les luttes
contre des inondations moi même sur la
commune dans gtmer et qui borde le Rhône
je peux vous dire que les travaux sur la
digue parce que le site nucléaire de
Pierrelatte est en aval à une douzaine
de kilomètres ce sont des travaux
absolument colossaux qui ont été
réalisés en cas de crue millénaire dont
les experts disaient que même en cas de
criminella alors on n'était pas sûr que
la centrale serait touchée mais malgré
ça
ça a été fait donc sincèrement je pense
que sur tout ce qu'on appelait stress
test protection etc la France a été en
pointe nous avons fait tout ce que nous
devions faire et ça a servi de modèle en
Europe et dans le monde parce que je
vais pas parce que des ministres de
l'incarnait mais parce que l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire française détenait
détient toujours je crois une très belle
image
honnêtement l'histoire M6 j'ai même
scrupule à vouloir raconter cette un
désaccord je sais pas c'est pas la
question et c'est même pas le reportage
parce qu'on me propose de de comment ça
n'est pas en direct
ils sont en retard j'ai un train je me
souviens très bien j'ai rendez-vous le
lendemain matin très tôt je dois prendre
l'Eurostar pour rencontrer le ministre
britannique de l'énergie ce que je dis a
fait l'objet de de communiquer
officielle ils sont en retard en
permanence je leur dis que j'ai le train
et à force on me demande de commenter
par avance un reportage que je n'ai pas
la possibilité de regarder que les
spectacles téléspectateurs ont pu voir
mais moi pas donc moi commenter des
reportages que je ne vois pas ça ne me
plaît pas je dis j'en ai marre je me
casse pas très élégant effectivement je
savais pas que mon micro était branché
donc j'ai dit je me casse je parce que
d'autres ont dû dire pire dans dans une
carrière professionnelle et je suis
parti et je suis allé prendre l'Eurostar
et je suis allé à Londres n'y voyez
franchement
aucune raison je d'un point de vue
politique je n'aurais eu que de bonnes
raisons de me réjouir qu'on me pose des
questions sur ce qu'on sur ce qu'on
avait fait après vous kushima parce que
très sincèrement je pense que c'était
exemplaire
peut-être beaucoup plus long mais j'ai
deux questions
sur je vais peut-être vous les poser à
la suite pour que vous puissiez faire
une réponse globale
la question c'est elle vous a déjà été
partiellement posée mais c'est sur
Flamanville et les problématiques de
Flamanville
vous avez eu différents angles qui a été
qui ont été abordés mais la Cour des
comptes si on parle de l'aspect
financier estime qu'il y a eu sur
Flamanville un manque de villes gilance
des autorités de tutelles et donc c'est
peut-être là dessus que j'aimerais vous
demander vous poser la question
et en fait quand même l'interrogation
comme de nombreuses personnalités qu'on
a auditionnées nous ont fait part du
fait qu'au démarrage les travaux
d'ingénierie de détails étaient à peine
entamé que les études de sûreté ou
encore le référence d'exclusion de
rupture a été peu ou pas engagée c'est
également le constat qui a été fait dans
un rapport de Jean-Martin Folz
[Musique]
nucléaire civile comme aujourd'hui
j'aimerais vous interroger donc sur la
question de la démocratie de la
politique énergétique lorsque vous étiez
interrogé à propos d'un référendum sur
le nucléaire après Fukushima vous
répondiez que les citoyens
s'exprimeraient lors des votes de
l'élection de 2012 c'était ça votre
réponse il y avait un scrutin majeur
pour le pays or ils ont voté pour un
programme prévoir rien l'arrêt d'un
certain nombre de centrales depuis il y
a pas eu de véritables débats publics
sur le nucléaire en France et après
tous les problèmes Fukushima les
nombreux problèmes on entend de plus en
plus parler aussi médiatiquement liés à
la maintenance le vieillissement du parc
les failles du parc nucléaire cet hiver
est-ce qu'il ne vous semble pas de temps
si on veut avoir une vraie ce que vous
avez prenez au démarrage qu'on soit pour
une option pour une autre qu'il y a un
vrai débat public transparent rationnel
dans ce pays sur la relance du nucléaire
plutôt que les choses soient imposées du
haut sans réel débat public
je réponds à vos deux questions je
prends la seconde puisque j'ai vos mots
en tête bon ça c'est une question qui
faudrait poser au gouvernement actuel
par mois
à l'époque la question de se posait pas
donc mon avis sur le sujet vous
apportera peu
oui justement je vais y venir
en 2011
alors même que les conséquences d'abord
l'enchaînement des faits sur Fukushima
et ses conséquences pour la sûreté du
nucléaire sont en cours d'études par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire avec une
revue systématique proposée un référent
je me souvenais absolument pas de cette
réponse mais elle ne m'étonne pas
proposer en 2011 un référendum alors
qu'on est à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle que j'ai dit bah écoutez
les nos concitoyens
s'exprimeront l'année prochaine lors de
l'élection présidentielle c'est tout à
fait plausible et je continue de de le
penser même si je me souvenais pas de
cette citation
ensuite vous dites ils l'ont fait et ils
ont décidé mais moi je ne mets pas en
cause la légitimité démocratique de de
leur choix oui il y a eu un accord VRPs
avec les
55 ans que j'évoquais tout à l'heure le
candidat Hollande devenu président
Hollande a été élu je ne je ne le remets
pas en cause la légitimité démocratique
n'est pas en cause maintenant
permettez-moi de dire que ça n'est pas
parce que les Français ont voté que
cette loi a été adoptée par le Parlement
que c'est une belle loi
utile à notre pays si je pense l'inverse
et je pense l'inverse je pense que c'est
une loi
qui n'a pas de sens je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure et d'ailleurs dont le la
démonstration est faite par la loi de
programmation qui suit si je me souviens
bien fin 2015 vous pouvez comparer ce
que dit la loi et ce que dit six mois
après la programmation pluriannuelle
elles ne sont pas en cohérence on peut
penser ce qu'on veut mais à six mois
d'intervalle même gouvernement même
protagoniste on peut imaginer qu'on peut
avoir une une cohérence donc est-ce
qu'il faut un référendum sur l'énergie
moi titre personnel je ne le pense pas
maintenant
ça n'est pas de ma responsabilité
aujourd'hui et vous pouvez penser
autrement sur le rapport de la Cour des
comptes que vous évoquez d'un mot pour
ma gouverne il date de quelle date
en tout cas pas pour donc nous étions au
gouvernement on est d'accord il est
postérieur
bon moi parce que le
seul rapport de la Cour des comptes dont
je me souviens très bien et qui est
publié en janvier 2012 il porte sur les
coups du nucléaire puis-je comparer à ce
moment-là du coup caché ou
d'insuffisance de prise en compte du
coût du démantèlement etc etc et la Cour
des comptes fait justice de cela en
disant il n'y a pas de coût caché et
deuxièmement combien même on
augmenterait le démantèle le coût du
démantèlement et des déchets ça nous
augmenterait au grand maximum que de 5%
sur sur longue durée quant à quant à le
Pr lorsque j'arrive aux fonctions qui
ont été les miennes
le chantier est en cours
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous pensez
que et on nous dit il y a des
difficultés il va y avoir des retards
etc je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure quelle
est la suggestion que le
un ministre de l'énergie ou plus haut
que le ministre de l'Énergie le Premier
ministre le président de la République
disent j'ordonne la réduction chantier
non ça n'a pas de sens
d'autant que au fur et à mesure les
bâtisseurs et notamment les les gens des
travaux publics puisque ça portait à
l'époque on était encore de la phase de
travaux publics du béton pour pour finir
faire simple vous disent bon bah voilà
on l'a rencontré un certain nombre de
difficultés mais on croit qu'on est en
train de de les résoudre c'est compliqué
de dire à ce moment-là maintenant
un mot aussi si vous le permettez je
vais être très court
l'industrie et notamment
l'industrie exigeante comme les
nucléaire c'est normal que vous
rencontriez un certain nombre de
difficultés lorsque vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la tête de série si on faisait
le compte dans dans l'automobile dans
tous les dans la dans l'aéronautique et
l'espace l'espace les fusées combien de
fusées n'ont pas n'ont pas fonctionné
avant d'atteindre les résultats que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui lorsque vous avez
des projets ambitieux et le Pr est la
troisième génération le son c'est normal
que vous rencontriez des difficultés au
départ et qu'on vous lissez sur longue
période étant donné ce que rapporte les
kilowatt-heure que vous produisez par la
filière nucléaire ça n'est pas très
grave c'est sur l'instant
agaçant et ça pose de vrais problèmes
mais sur la longue durée si le si les
EPR que la France s'apprête si j'ai bien
compris à lancer son supposé duré 50-60
ans 80 ans peut-être 100 ans croyez moi
que le premier EPR de Flamanville est
connu un certain nombre de difficultés
je sûr que dans 20-25 ou 30 ans ce soit
un sujet majeur
j'ai juste retrouvé c'est le rapport qui
est remis le 9 juillet 2020 et donc je
les cite ils disent c'est des livres
résulte d'estimation de départ
irréalistes d'une mauvaise organisation
de la réalisation du projet par EDF et
d'un manque de vigilance des autorités
de tutelle et d'une méconnaissance de la
perte et compétence technique des
industriels de la filière ces années
après la construction du réacteur de
niveau 2 donc c'est bien évidemment un
rapport postérieur qui analyse le
déboire de Flamanville mais qu'il
indique aussi c'est là-dessus que je
vous interrogeais sur le manque de
vigilance des autorités de tutelles mais
vous venez d'y répondre quelque part en
disant pour moi il n'y avait pas de
vigilance quelque part excessive à voir
c'était une un premier tête de fil et ce
n'est pas grave qu'on peut laisser
dériver les finances à ce moment là
c'est je résume avec mes mots ce que je
viens d'entendre oui
c'est important et pas avec les miens je
vous ai pas dit il n'y avait pas de
vigilance
permettez-moi juste d'un mot de vous
dire que un rapport en 2020 c'est pas
exactement la même situation que
novembre 2010 10 ans après tout le monde
a toujours raison la question qui est
posée c'est de se remettre sur l'instant
où vous travaillez donc novembre 2010 en
novembre 2010
EDF sort
une décennie avant que 97 le dernier
le la livraison du dernier réacteur
précédent on est donc on est 12-13 ans
après tout le monde pense EDF pense tout
le monde pense que nous n'avons pas
perdu la main que nos ingénieurs seront
faire a posteriori probablement avait
été sous-estimé beaucoup de difficultés
que que vous venez de dire mais très
franchement
n'attendez pas
d'un ministre qu'il puisse jauger
lui-même il ne le pourra jamais il est
obligé de s'en remettre à des experts
la qualité des couches successives et
des strates successives de béton qu'on
lui dit nécessaire pour créer ce que
j'appelais tout à l'heure le
récupérateur en cas de fuite au cas
ministre ne saura jamais faire bien
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
la précision de vos réponses et le temps
que vous avez consacré à notre
commission d'enquête qui permet parfois
de
faire cet exercice qui est pas simple de
recontextualisation
et c'est vrai que j'avais pas pris
conscience du contenu jusque là du du
rapport énergie 2050 qui vous est remis
début 2012 et qui dans ces
recommandations souligne déjà la
nécessité de prendre l'initiative de
réexaminer en profondeur les règles du
marché intérieur de l'énergie qui
suggère de ne se passe fixer d'objectif
sur la question de la part du nucléaire
mais de poursuivre le développement de
la quatrième génération et de préparer
l'allongement de la durée de vie de la
génération actuelle objectif auquel vous
ajoutez dans vos déclarations la
nécessité de se fixer comme priorité la
maîtrise des consommations d'une part et
le développement des énergies
décarbonées renouvelables et nucléaire
d'autre part voilà je crois que 10 ans
plus tard je doute que les conclusions
de notre rapport soient très différentes
de ces grandes orientations fixées il y
a déjà 10 ans merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre et bonne journée à à toutes et
à tous merci à vous